nine years it's been nine years since
skyrim has released
some days it feels like i've played it
for an eternity some days it feels like
i've just started
today i want to talk about that why is
skyrim a game that hasn't had a
significant update since 2016
still played and enjoyed by the masses
after all these years
i do want to clarify that this won't be
a review or evaluation
those types of videos discuss all sorts
of mechanics whether it's in a positive
and negative light
the point of this series is to answer
the simple question why does this game
still have an active player base after
years of no official content
whether you want to watch the full video
or skip around there will be times them
to lay out in detail so you can skip to
the times in the video you prefer to
watch
regardless of how you decide to watch it
though relax as we talk about skyrim and
how it's managed to keep people playing
after nine years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've always been very particular about
first impressions they set the tone for
almost any engagement
so let's start with skyrim's first
impression while not as popular nowadays
games sometimes have clips or cut scenes
in the main menu should the player not
touch the controller for quite a bit of
time while skyrim doesn't have a
cutscene it does provide the player with
a fantastic start to the game's
soundtrack the composer of the intro was
jeremy soule
who also composed music for guild wars 2
and the previous elder scrolls titles
morrowind and oblivion
he was told that the intro was not meant
to be melodic as it's supposed to be
sung by a large group of vikings so a
heavier tone to the music would be more
appropriate
the main elements of the song are taken
from the intro of morrowind such as the
melody and the drums in the beginning
the choir was only made up of 30 people
which was copied and changed and pitched
multiple times to make it seem like
there was hundreds of people singing
sound designer mark lampert stated that
no matter how many times you hear it
you still get goosebumps and that
couldn't be more true the song is spoken
in a whole new language which is the
dragon language the developers created
for this game
it's still unclear who specifically is
singing but regardless it's people who
are praying for the dragonborn so that
he doesn't fall in combat before he
completes his prophecy
which is to fight back the dragons and
defeat alduin the song references the
dragonborn
stating that they are of human and
dragon descent and now they have the
strength that rivals the sun
the lyrics of the song are telling us
what we're going to be doing referencing
the dragonborn
and alduin before the game even starts
except as new players
we didn't know what that meant for new
players it's a cool tune to listen to to
either get them excited before playing
or to listen while changing the various
settings in the menus
for returning players it's like a ritual
to almost listen to at least the first
minute before you start your playthrough
again
and hopping back into the world of
skyrim as the song just never gets old
the in-game
music was also mostly composed by
jeremy's soul as well
with the intention of having the music
react to the player's interactions
all the music had been laid out
specifically to be played at certain
points to match the mood and all the
songs have this combination of
similarity and contrast
any song within one engagement sounds
fairly similar but the moment the
engagement changes
the contrast comes in to react to what
is happening within the game these
engagements can be very minute
walking around the world of skyrim
exploring its various mountains or just
taking in the atmosphere
provides the player with the joyful and
calming tracks of music to go with the
mood
but when you walk into a city that
changes as skyrim plays music that is
the same feeling of joy and calmness but
now you're surrounded by npcs all doing
different tasks
so maybe walk in the town some may be
buying produce and some maybe having a
verbal argument
so skyrim plays a different soundtrack
of music just for the towns
even though these are different
engagements the similarity stays the
same
but if we change it entirely and instead
of walking around skyrim we're in the
heat of battle the battle music helps
guide the interaction
making it feel more real but imagine if
these were flit and as awkward as it
sounds it can happen in a playthrough
nobody likes the sound of hearing battle
music when the only thing around you is
just grass and trees
it creates this uncomfortable atmosphere
as you have no clue where the enemy is
and
the music wouldn't just turn on randomly
for no reason another thing to mention
though is not just the music but
the sounds itself the clashing of metal
the shouts even just hearing your own
footsteps
nothing ever sounds out of place for
example the dwemer are known to be
technologically advanced with tons of
working machinery and technology
so when you enter a dwarven ruin you
should be greeted with the sounds of
running cogs
steam being exhausted from the pipes and
clanks of metal rubbing up against one
another
and that's exactly what skyrim does
adding together the music the
environment and the sound of combat
and everything just plays out so
smoothly it makes you feel like you were
there in the world itself
and while we're on the topic let's talk
about the world of skyrim
and its environment one of skyrim's
strongest points is its environment and
exploration
skyrim consists of nine holds all which
have a capital which is the main city
marked on the map
there's also seven towns or settlements
spread throughout these holds as well
while it isn't exactly recommended to
new players as the first few main quests
help you gather your footing in the
game's world
the moment you exit the cave in the
beginning of the game you're free to do
whatever you want
only the first 15 minutes or so in the
last few main quests are where the game
keeps you locked into doing something
linear
in between that is where the game truly
shines and even if a player decides to
go off the beaten path
and explore the player gets rewarded for
these choices
nearby the cave we come out of is a
standing stone altar a mine overrun by
bandits an abandoned hut and a town
going to any of these locations you
could teach the player what the icons
mean on the map and what to expect as
once you understand the concept it never
leaves your brain
it also shows the variety of each of
these places standing stones provide the
player with buffs if they choose one
it's nothing crazy but can be catalogued
for the future if they need a specific
stone the mine introduces the player to
more combat but it's more free form as
you
aren't required to fight any of these
enemies and you can leave them for
another time if you want to
but should you choose to clear out the
enemies more than likely either the
leader of the group or the leader's
resting place should have some items you
can take to equip your character or sell
for coin
for example going to clear spring tarn
seems like nothing too crazy as there's
just a hunter and some deer
but nearby is a cave and when explored
can reward the player with a bow of the
hunt
normally just a bow that does damage to
animals nothing wild as a daedric weapon
or one of a kind armor but
it's not just a dead end with nothing to
reward the player it gives the player a
reason to actually go to these places
and explore them as
now the player understands there's a
reward for completing these areas now
and it's a mystery what they could
stumble upon in their next dungeon
as for now i do want to emphasize the
previous point with two locations
redwater den and white river watch both
of these locations immerse the player in
the world in different ways and have
very different experiences
to them while also reinforcing my point
before you never know what you're going
to be getting when you enter a new area
so let's assume the player has just left
whiterun for the first time maybe doing
a few main quests but
probably wants to explore a bit more
first so they head out to the left of
whiterun and they come across white
river watch
the icon on the map is a cave so the
player knows that this is most likely
some low level dungeon
going towards the cave you meet a bandit
or two outside
once that's done you can head in and
clear the rest of the group including
the leader
for someone who doesn't take the time to
read everything going on or take in the
dungeon
this is a pretty much a quick cash grab
for them as they can sell the trash gear
and equip the better ones for the
character
either way the players still gaining
something from it but if you look at the
items item's intake in the scenery it's
not just as simple as a cave with
typical bandits
one of the bandits outside of the cave
drops a note it's addressed to a man
named roll doof
by no one saying hajvar azvar is annoyed
at someone for playing tricks on his
uncle
referencing his past actions which were
putting nails on a chair and stealing
the ledger
seems to be some sort of squabble
between these two heading inside we meet
another bandit i'll fear the blind
you can quickly notice that this isn't
just some made up name as by walking to
him you can talk to him and tell them
that you're one of the bandits and sneak
by
he's actually blind it's confusing why
this bandit group made somebody blind be
the watchman
so it leaves some curiosity to the
player looking at the table you could
find that this is all fear's book
reading it shows that the pages are
empty reinforcing that
he is still blind this doesn't give any
more of the info on the cave it's more
just a slight chuckle should the player
end up reading this book
in front of him going further you can
see two bandits and a wolf inside a cage
next to them
instead of engaging if the player waits
you can overhear their conversation
which talks about plans to go hajvar and
his uncle all fear
now we can see some connections it's var
wanted to make his uncle part of the
group and not just make him dead weight
so he gave him the watchman position but
most of the group didn't seem to like
that as kind of seeing is more of a
requirement for that job
these two plan to use the wolf to help
fight hajvar but they're worried as it's
untrained and it could turn on them
this is why they haven't enacted the
plan yet as they're only going to get
one chance at this continuing through to
the end we end up meeting the leader who
is hajvar and on his body is his journal
the journal catalogs some of his recent
endeavors and any ideas that come to his
mind from reading this we can discover
that he hasn't had too much luck with
the raids or hunts as the guards are on
full alert from the war and pressure
that any moment that the guards will
raid the cave is frightening the men one
of the later entries is about a mutiny
had taken place
at some point in the past but thankfully
all fear was there and overheard it
we know from the guards with the wolf
that the previous mutiny wouldn't be the
last so it seemed
varaz having trouble getting his men to
trust him or at the very least keep them
in line
the two members who managed to escape
were a nord woman in a khajiit named asa
and rajar
who we can find near frostmire crypt the
last entry talks about a previous
successful raid in which they got some
weird cargo and a live wolf they were
also going to kill the wolf for food but
hezevar decided he wanted to keep it and
drain it
we can also hear this part for the
bandits as they plan to use the wolf to
kill hajvar when they train it so
everything's slowly coming together so
to recap hajvar is the leader of the
bandits of this group the members of the
cave grew tired of his command and
thought he'd be better off dead
so mutiny was created it was then
stopped but two of the members survived
and escaped the group didn't like how he
ruled and thought that his uncle was
useless as he was blind and
the fact that they gave him such an
important job as watching the entrance
annoyed a few members this is where the
second mutiny would soon start if the
dragonborn of course didn't kill all
them before they got the chance to
as they wanted to wait for the wolf to
be trained so that the plane didn't
backfire
but that's not the full story of this
group's members as those two members we
talked about before isa and rajar who
had escaped their mutiny plan after it
backfired and fled to froshmere crypt
can be found there of course upon
arriving isa is attacked by her fellow
bandits and talks of a stolen blade and
some mysterious lady
she was part of another group but
someone stole the boss's sword and he
flipped out
killing her during this interaction and
reading her journal can start a whole
new side quest called the pale lady
sparing some details and involves
finding this sword and then you can
either banish the spirit by taking the
sword and killing it or putting it back
in laying its rest
through this quest you'll encounter
three notable people kir rajar and
iso each of whom have either a note or
journal you can read
reading all three completes the story
right away the isa and rajar from
hajvar's journal back in white river
watch is
these two as it says in the first line
of isis journal that they left the white
river gang which of course
white river watch white river gang it's
the same people they soon stumbled upon
this group and were recruited by the new
leader here
isil led the mining operations and rajar
was part of the raids
isis group of miners found what looked
like to be a cave with some forest
inside of it
this ended up causing some problems as
rajar the khajiit was experiencing
nightmares and insomnia
and something about some pale lady which
from doing the quest and reading the
journals most likely had to do with the
uncovering of the forest that her group
had found
this then caused brazar to go wild then
constantly asking for keir's sword as
according to his voice in his head
which is the pale lady once the sword
was put back he'll be able to go back to
his normal self so he's doing anything
he can possible to stop these nightmares
when you enter deep in the cave you can
speak to kyr who afterward will die
he talks about rajar ambushing him and
taking the sword continuing down the
path you can find rajar in his stolen
blade
this is where the quest then gives you
the option of putting the weapon back
or killing them both while the white
river watch and frostmere crypt don't
actually have any direct connections to
one another from reading and the context
clues you can piece together the whole
adventure these groups of bandits go on
just from taking the time to read some
of the journals the game provides
our next example is redwater den if
white river watch gave the player an
interesting adventure due to the player
needing to actually read into the
location by the many journals
redwater den does the opposite it gives
that same feeling of a successful
adventure
while just being in the moment you don't
need to read any journals to understand
what's going on here
redwater den from afar may seem like a
hut with some possible gold and loot
this hell but
something's a bit different as the
building is crumbling and there are
guards watching the entrance
when going near the guards they make
remarks towards the players saying
either buy something or get lost
so now we know it's some sort of store
but it's still suspicious considering
the previous details and that the
entrance is some sort of cellar door
asking the dealer she says that redwater
den is the best purveyors of scuma
outside of bellmore
so they sell scuma which explains the
suspicious business location and the
guard detail
down the hall is where the customers sit
and enjoy the skooma all of which are
either unconscious
coughing or in one case dead at the end
of the hall is a locked door which is
concerning but could be easily passed
off as maybe some employee only area
where they produce the skooma and don't
want customers going in and snatching
free product
drinking the skooma makes the player go
a little hazy until they collapse and
awaken a cell this is where the story of
redwater den starts the owners lure in
people to test their new skooma and use
the water from the spring inside the den
to make it more potent making the user
pass out this is a deal between the
vampires and the owners
the owners get money from the customers
who purchase the scuma and the vampires
then take the unconscious clientele and
make them into their thrall so they have
an army under their command while as
interesting as that
is we clearly don't want that and we
need to escape the game provides you
with many different ways to escape this
cell which
we'll delve deeper into in a few minutes
but regardless of how you end up
escaping
the whole den is now aware of your
position so you have to fight to escape
which can either be through the entrance
we saw earlier or go deeper into the
cave where the spring water is
other option works and will inevitably
loop you back to the beginning so it
doesn't matter
that's redwater den there isn't a quest
for waking up in the cell it's just a
scripted event that happens in the area
so
you may not have seen this unless you
went along with what was happening in
the den
now of course you can get more details
about this area from reading a few
journals like vulpines but
it's not necessary to get the main idea
like i said before
with white river watch you end up having
this successful adventure by being
immersed into the game and taking in the
story through journals with redwater den
you have that same exact effect but
having it be a
real-time event with combat and dialogue
no needing to sift through journals and
pause the game to do so two different
places and two different ways the game
makes you interested in the world but
at the same time it's the same malcolm
at the end and that truly is the
strongest part about skyrim
of course these two locations aren't the
only ones in the game with this style of
exploration
it's everywhere in this game these are
just too notable to me as they are
absolute polar opposites of one another
in the way that they're experienced
and sometimes areas like these are
easier to understand but not every
location is like that even after nine
years
people still have questions about what
happened in rorickstead for example
brooksted is a nearby town you'll mostly
run into on your travels in the
wilderness or during the red guard quest
in whiterun
regardless the town seems very simple
but slightly out of place
it's got maybe one to two quests at most
and that's about it worksat is mostly
known for having terrible farming
conditions but at the same time it's
also known for having some of the best
product in the hold so how is that even
possible what makes it even more
confusing is that the town has an
abundance of soul gems why do farmers
need soul gems
the only person who would use those is
the talent healer but one person clearly
doesn't need that many there have been
tons of theories on this town ranging
from immortality
daedric worship and other sinister
things sadly there is no definitive
answer with a lot of unanswered
questions and plot points but
it's something that many may not notice
during a playthrough as
you may just mistake it for a normal
town and of course workstat isn't the
only mystery this game offers there are
tons from the creation of the falmer the
disappearance of the dwemer and the eye
of magnus
all of which are confusing things that
exist in the game's story that players
have been trying to figure out for nine
years with no exact answer just
speculation and theory and even after
nine years of failure and no proven
answer
people are still looking into these
mysteries as later games are getting new
updates which could hint towards these
mysteries and finally drawing a
conclusion and getting a real answer
everything i've mentioned up until this
point has just been exploration
if skyrim can make the player feel
satisfaction by going through caves and
learning lore and story at their own
disposal then the sidequests of skyrim
are in a whole other league
sidequests are found everywhere in
skyrim and there's so many that it
should be a selling point in itself
there's over 100 side quests that skyrim
has and that's not including the faction
storylines or any of the three dlcs
taking into account skyrim's large world
and the amount of side quests that exist
there's a good chance you won't be able
to find all of them it's hard to choose
from all the quests that the game
provides so i'll just be picking some
that i find that are extremely unique
and
excellent storytelling and reward to
truly show the range of skyrim's quests
and
really how good they are the first quest
is a murder mystery there's a handful of
these that exist within the game but my
favorite has always been blood on the
ice
but on the ice is located in windhelm
and will randomly come up when visiting
the nearby graves as you approach three
witnesses and a guarder at the crime
scene
the guard is telling you to step back
you can question the guard and ask him
what is going on and this will start the
quest
apparently this isn't the first time
some woman has been found dead with her
body mutilated like this
the guard then hands the duty off to you
and you can question him why you should
be doing it instead of him
as he's a guard but thanks to the war
the men are stripped thin and can't
really focus on these crimes too much so
the war is more important you could
start by interviewing the witnesses to
gain some background information on what
happened after that you relay your
findings to the guard who instructs you
to report to the steward
of windhelm the steward is aware of
these murders as well but just like the
guard said he doesn't have many men to
use so there's not much he can do
once done you could talk to hellgrid who
will give you an autopsy of the body
saying it has some sloshing marks made
of some ancient nord tool that she would
most likely use it makes her a suspect
but she immediately clears up that
suspicion saying that if she was the
killer she wouldn't have mentioned that
detail
near the scene of the crime is a blood
trail and should the player follow the
broad shell it can lead us to an
abandoned house you can investigate many
of the different areas in here like the
pots the meat and the chest
i'll give slight clues on what's going
on but near the wall on the shelf is an
amulet
with some papers and a journal these are
our first clues to finding the murderer
the reason why there's so many papers as
we talked to windhelm resident viola
she's been notifying the people of the
murderer and to stay
safe but the murder is taking them down
so people aren't notified as quickly
according to calixo the amulet is a
heirloom of windhelm which is usually
worn by the court mage the journal is
more of a diary for the murderer
explaining his thoughts and the reason
for killing all the people he does in a
specific way
the murderer discovered this new type of
magic called flesh magic except it's not
as simple as casting a spell it requires
more prep and analysis which is why he's
killing people and experimenting on them
the bottom floor also has a cabinet with
a false panel which leads to an altar
and some human remains there's also a
journal on the altar displaying the list
of required items like bone fragments
ligaments blood and flesh that he uses
for the experiments with the information
in hand we can then talk to the steward
and present our case and claim that
wundforth the court mage is guilty of
murder
afterwards he'll then walk the court
mates to the quarters and throw him in
jail which you could of course watch for
yourself we can then now walk the
streets of windhelm confident that we
solve the case
until three days go by and find out that
another murder has happened
we put the wrong dude in jail this then
starts the second part of blood on the
ice your next step is to receive
information from the court mage you just
imprisoned just like before he says that
he was trying to catch the murderer not
murder people which now of course with
the early information is now known to be
truth he asks what made you convict him
in the first place anyway and you
provide him with the proof that you
showed the steward he is familiar with
the amulet that we showed him it's a
necromancer's amulet wunderth has been
doing some research on the side and has
noticed a pattern of killings within
this person
so it could be that a person is a
necromancer he lets us know that
following the pattern of killings that
there might be another murder tonight
and that we need to keep guard
you patrol near the stone quarter and
catch the murderer in the act who
happens to be calyxo the one we
previously showed the amulet to you
either have the option of killing him
before he kills his next victim or if he
then does kill the victim he will then
flee to the house which you can chase
him to
as much as i would have loved to show
this patrolling part of the quest my
game ended up glitching and said i had
already completed the patrolling so the
moment i stepped out kalixo was already
running
regardless though we can then find him
and kill him of course we can report
this to the steward and let him know
that calixo is the one that actually did
the killings but we can't exactly throw
him in jail as he's dead
but at the very least we can let wound
firth out of prison with that out of the
way we've officially saved windhelm and
there won't be any killing anymore
for real this time blood on the ice has
always been a unique quest to me as it's
not just some simple crime that we can
solve the twist of course being that we
screwed up in the beginning and put the
wrong dude in jail imagine if we never
came back and he was just sitting in
jail the whole time for the rest of his
life as
he was falsely accused a nice fantastic
plot twist that the player never really
expects their first time playing while
the side quests of skyrim could fall
under their own
roof of types of quests there's also a
subsection of these called daedric
quests there are 15 daedric princes that
exist in skyrim that we can do quests
for each of them will give us a daedric
artifact as a token of gratitude from
them to us
all the artifacts and the quests
themselves are unique in their own way
but one has always stood out to me which
was a night to remember not only is this
a daedra quest it's one of the funniest
quests this game has to offer
a night to remember starts when walking
into a random tavern the player that may
encounter a mage named sam who
challenges you to a drinking contest sam
wagers that if you win you get his staff
you could of course opt to challenge him
or not and by accepting the dragonborn
will get more and more intoxicated with
every drink starting with coherent
sentences too a few messed up words then
to full-on gibberish afterwards the you
then black out and arrive at the temple
of dybella and markarth one of the
priestesses of dybella walks over and
questions you on your rude behavior
obviously we blacked out and we have no
idea what's going on so we happen to ask
her what happened and she refuses until
we've picked up our mess which is
ingredients all over the floor when
picking up the items one of the items we
come across is a drop
note by sam which talks about the
repairing of the staff we don't exactly
know what happened so we'll keep this
for later as it could be useful once the
cleaning is done she'll then mention you
were discussing things about a marriage
and then a goat
to which we then proceeded to lose our
temper and throw stuff everywhere
now we need to retrace our steps and try
to find sam the priestess will point you
to rorke's that is that's where we
mentioned about the goat the player then
discovers while on a drunken rampage we
ended up taking a goat from a farmer and
selling it to a giant
thankfully nearby is the one giant we
sold the go to by interacting with the
goat the giant then becomes hostile so
he'll attack us on site once killed you
can then safely escort the goat back to
his farmer
the farmer is more than delighted to see
his prize go and reveals to the
dragonborn that while we kidnap the go
we did leave a note explaining why which
was a little bit hard to read but had
something about repaying yasoda and
whiterun so naturally we then meet
yasoda who is also angered at us too
mentioning how we need to return her
ring
isla can explain to us what happened and
according to the dragonborn we were
talking about marrying this very fine
woman from witch miss grove there was
this romantic story of how we met
and everything yasoda is only relevant
here because she gave us the ring we
were gonna propose with except we never
paid her which explains the repaying is
sold apart from rorke's dead
traveling to witch miss grove we find
our maid of honor moira who happens to
be a hag raven completely ignoring the
obvious you can of course ask her for
the ring back
and she gets defensive which then you
have no choice but to attack and kill
her you then bring the ring back
to yasoda she is saddened to hear that
the marriage didn't work out as it would
have been really cool to celebrate it at
morven's scar like we mentioned
this is the last location we need and we
are finally piecing everything together
marvinskar is a fort filled with mages
of all types and apparently where we
were going to celebrate our marriage
in the back of the fort is a portal
which leads us to misty grove a
beautiful but
concerning place as the skies could lead
a different color so it's safe to say
we're in a different world
walking further we see a dinner table
with a group of people eating and
drinking with sam nearby
we then talked to sam and converse about
how wild the trip we had was and how we
have the parts to repair the staff but
sam declined says there's no need the
staff was never broken he just wanted to
see if we could earn the right to wield
it and that sam
isn't actually sam sam is actually
sanguine the daedric prince of
debauchery he made up the lie about the
staff to get us to spread merriment and
according to him he hasn't had that much
fun
in at least a hundred years and as a
reward we get to keep his staff which is
the sanguine's rose this enchantment
allows you to summon a daedra companion
for
60 seconds so now we have the full story
when we first met sam he talked about a
place where the drinks never stopped
flowing this happened to be misty grove
we got so intoxicated that when we left
we ended up confessing
our love to a hagraven but we needed a
ring which is the one we stole from
yasoda
of course you noticed we took it from
her so we needed to pay her back which
is why we stole the farmer's goat to get
some money
i guess on the way sam quote unquote
broke the staff and needed us to repair
it which is why we went to the temple of
dabella
as they have a ton of alchemy
ingredients in there an absolutely
astonishing story
my only gripe with this quest has always
been the ability to persuade
bribe or intimidate your way past
objectives as i find the actual journey
of going through when uncovering what
you did is way more fun than skipping it
a night to remember is a nice break from
the usual serious quests and
it's pretty refreshing to have a laugh
once in a while and speaking of those
serious quests we come to our last two
which are the forbidden legend and no
one escapes it in a mine the forbidden
legend is one of the many quests that
can be started by reading a book
this one in particular is called the
lost legends while it can be found in
many places the two most notable have
been a corpse in reach water rock and
the orc librarian in the college of
winterhold upon reading the book you
were then given the quest
the forbidden legend reading the book
gives us an insight on some historical
folk tales like the pale lady which we
talked about a couple minutes ago the
red eagle and the one we care about
archmage golder there was a powerful
wizard named galder a way back when
a smart and wise man but he was
mysteriously murdered many suspected his
sons were the reason for it his three
sons had fled the night of his murder
and the king ordered some of his guards
and battle mage lord gearman to track
them down
the brothers were then separated in
different parts of skyrim and killed at
different locations the king ordered
anything about them to be removed and
destroyed as to cover up the incident
the only location that was mentioned in
the book was a place called fulgenthar
so
now the quest is to uncover the mystery
and we can start there nearby the burial
site is a camp of the journal from a man
named denas velen
this journal was used to catalogue his
thoughts as the days went by it seemed
like danas was also dead set on
uncovering this mystery the same as us
except he had more devious tendencies to
him which were becoming a lot more
noticeable
fortunately for him he ended up meeting
a group of adventurers who also sounded
in way over their heads but he was okay
with joining them as he thought the
draugr in the cave would be more focused
on them and not him meaning he could
make it out alive
and judging from his journal it seems
like denos was not native to skyrim as
from the mention of a place called
bravil
which is located in cyrodiil and that he
was almost inclined to swim
if the trip was going to take too long
meaning they came by boat so this seems
to be some sort of international tale
that we're dealing with pogenther is
plagued with loads of draugr and traps
are anything but scarce
immediately we see the dragon claw
keyholes and the movable pillars meaning
that there was puzzles that needed to be
solved and
somebody has a dragon claw with them the
puzzles aren't too difficult they just
take some minor thinking and eventually
we then make it to danos's corpse on his
body is a note which is describing the
story just a little bit better galder
was a powerful and respected being so
much so that his sons grew resentful of
him and wanted his power and prestige
for themselves one of the brothers
jerich discovered that the source of his
power was from their father's amulet so
the three brothers mcrule cygnus and
jerich all killed their father and split
the amulet into three fragments to share
the power this is when the book keeps up
with the night of the murder where
mcrule ended up dying in fulgenter
headed away in a crypt with the ivory
claw
jerk the oldest was pursued by the mage
lord himself and died in a ruined city
and the middle child cygnus was cornered
near the southern parts of skyrim who
also challenged german to a duel and
then of course was promptly killed
galder the father ends up residing in
reach water rock so to find the amulet
we need to visit the three brothers
then go meet the father and reach water
rock and hopefully get this thing
repaired each of the three locations
where the brothers are buried houses
pretty much the same things a large
crypt filled with draugr traps and
puzzles so i'll skip some of the
repetitive details
eventually he'll make it to the burial
site of mcrule the youngest located
further in fulgenther he's the only
brother without a weakness but
not having a weakness is his weakness as
you'll soon find out he's the easiest to
slay out of the three
he does have some thrall that come alive
when you fight him but they'll die if he
dies so the quicker you clean him up the
easier this gets signus is the middle
child and an archer and he's located in
german's hall
he has the ability to clone himself the
issue is that if you kill the two fake
clones he will then disappear and
reappear with even more clones making
this a never-ending cycle
on top of that they all use unrelenting
force shooting you to the ground
multiple times
it's more tedious than challenging as
he's pretty weak too it's just the
clones are a bit annoying
his weakness is that the clones have
different helmets than him he wears the
ancient nord helmet the clones do not
so just look out for that lastly is
juric the oldest who is located in
sarthal except you can't go in without
doing the quest
under sarthal for those who don't know
bethesda has a mechanic in place for
these sorts of things called lock off
dungeons as the name suggests bethesda
locks off either parts of the dungeon or
the whole dungeon itself to prevent
people from going
inside this is mostly due to there being
a quest in that dungeon and they don't
want players either screwing up some of
the scripts and commands in there or
discovering a secret they weren't
supposed to know just yet we'll delve
more into this section a little bit
later when we discuss the college of
winterhold but at the end of the dungeon
is jirek the oldest for a melee
character he's pretty much a pushover
for a mage he's a bit difficult
jira can be surrounded by three elements
fire storm and ice
whatever is surrounding him is the
element he's resistant to all three
brothers have a unique weapon that they
drop as well once killed mkrule has an
ancient nord sword with health
absorption
cygnus has an ancient oard bow with
magical absorption and jerich has a
staff that deals more damage on hit and
makes the user take more magic damage
once collecting all three fragments from
the bodies we can then go to reach water
rock in the burial site at reachwater
rock there are three pedestals where you
place the fragments
once all three are placed the spirits of
the brothers appear once more and you
have to fight them in a one-on-one again
the tactics are pretty much the same so
nothing really changes upon defeating
the brothers they disappear
galder arrives and combines the
fragments and gives you his amulet as
the reward which increases your magic
your health and your stamina all by 30
points the quest was sort of like a
scavenger hunt that other quests have
but i've always been super fond of this
one as the story behind it is excellent
and the contrast between the brothers
makes the battles just way more intense
as each one is totally different
the previous quest has us going all
around skyrim in search for the mystery
while no one escapes sydney mine has us
staying in one location for the whole
quest
but we can't talk about this quest
without mentioning the force one
conspiracy
as this is a quest split between two
names the force warned conspiracy starts
the moment you enter marcarth as an
innocent bystander is killed for
seemingly no reason the murderer says
for the force sworn implying that the
force won't have invaded the walls the
guards reassure everyone that everything
is taken care of and there is no force
worn within the walls of markharth
afterwards a man named el trice
discusses with you the horrific scene
you just walked in on and says you
dropped a note in the confusion reading
it gives us the detail that he gave this
to us on purpose and it was never ours
to begin with we can then meet him at
the statue of talos and he explains
what's going on
the people of marcarth want an answer
for why people are dying by the force
horn and the guards are never doing
anything about it until the person is
killed the reason he's giving us the
quest is we're an outsider and that
hopefully we won't catch as much
attention as a townsfolk would so the
dragonborn must take up info
on two people margaret and weyland who
are the murderer and victim of the
killing the moment you walked in
margaret's room is located in the silver
blood inn and it also shows us details
that she was an imperial spy marcotte is
a stormcloak city so she must have been
snuffed out she also mentions a sonar
which that she was trying to get
evidence about waylon was paid as the
hitman to kill her by a man named nebos
the nose so we can investigate these two
now
thonar is the head of the silverblood
family in marcarth he knew she was an
imperial agent and had her killed but
that's not the full story
the force warner being used by thonar
long ago there was a force worn uprising
and instead of killing the leader
madanak he put them in jail and had them
be abused he would use the force worn
influence to kill competitors
agents and idiots as he says and as for
nepo's he was a force-worn agent in
disguise same as everyone else in the
house nepos is tired of it sending
people to their deaths for 20 years has
taken quite the effect on him
nepos gets maddenok's message and then
carries out the orders in the name of
the force warren
for a little bit of background knowledge
the force warren used to be the rightful
owners of the reach until the nords
invaded and took their land from them
they eventually battled back with an
uprising but ulfric came by with his
army of stormcloaks and crushed them
another force warner just trying to get
their land back from the nords but
obviously the stormcloaks are too big of
an army for them to handle this is what
started the conflict between the two
groups and the conspiracy going forward
in the first place we now have all the
info we need and we can relay this back
to el trees but when we go back to the
statue of talos we are then caught and
taken to jail this then starts the quest
no one escapes citing a mine the sydney
mine is a rough prison
the prisoners work for their time mining
ore until they drop so the silver bloods
can profit
most in here are from the forest horn
but some just happen to be in here and
joined madanak for their own personal
reasons
odhvan is like us innocent and framed
either way he was a murderer in the eyes
of the people so he might as well live
up to the name anyway
borgel was the leader of some bandits
but they weren't very tough as he says
and he's always respected strong
individuals when he got thrown in jail
he noticed the strength of the force
horn and decided to join them the issue
though
is why some of them are here like i said
most are force-worn and have been here
anywhere from a couple years to
longer than a decade either captured in
battle or just being caught doing
nefarious things
except one person in particular and
that's break break in this case was just
thrown in jail because he was talking to
matanot he wasn't even involved in the
uprising he just happened to know who he
was which of course is just enough for
the nords his daughter then offered
herself instead of braid to go to jail
so they killed his daughter in front of
him and still threw him in prison
a truly depressing tale when talking
with madanak he then explains the
previous history we just mentioned about
the force horn about their uprising etc
he then instructs you to prove your
loyalty to him by killing grishvar the
old man this
upcoming action can be performed the
moment you meet madanak or after you
kill grijvar but you are now technically
presented with two options
escape with the force warn or kill them
the game never really instructs you to
do this so you might just miss it
killing matanock reveals a note telling
us the location
of a secret exit we can take to escape
when exiting thonar is waiting outside
and congratulates us for killing him he
then gives you the silver blood ring as
reward you're also pardoned of your
crimes which as we know weren't crimes
to begin with
that's feeling a little bit empty as
it's clear thornar is an evil person
doing what he does to people who oppose
him and even in our case throwing an
innocent person in jail and his response
to intimidate us is saying we should be
thankful
instead of not being killed what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] alternatively we can
then side with the force warn and escape
together you could choose to fight with
the force warner if you want to but you
could also just spectate as fighting
ends up getting you a bounty
so spectating is probably just the best
idea regardless the force one will kill
the guards anyway and escape to a nearby
camp ending the quest
this quest has always been my favorite
as it gives the player the moral choice
of choosing between the lesser of two
evils the force worn a group of people
ran out of their home who just wanted
back but in the process of course killed
and enslaved many innocent people and
aren't stopping until they reclaimed the
reach or you could side with the silver
bloods and the guards who
look away from others crimes they
committed as they conspire with the
captured force worn together to hunt
down those who oppose them this is why i
saved this quest for last as this is
arguably one of the best quests in
skyrim in terms of storyline and
is the best example of how good these
side quests can be i would have loved to
talk about a bunch more but this video
would have been three to four hours long
at most
so some honorable mentions just in case
you wanted to know were in my time of
need house of horrors and the man who
cried wolf all of which being excellent
question are on par with the previous
ones mentioned
i said in the beginning i think these
quests truly show the diversity of
skym's quest but we haven't really
discussed how that diversity is also
shown
in the combat and its role play
capabilities skyrim's leveling system is
different from other games where some
games go based on only xp
skarm is entirely based off the skills
leveling up the more skills leveled up
the higher you go
just like any player experience bar it
becomes harder and harder to see
meaningful progress the higher you go up
but it's still noticeable these skills
are split into three trees with six
perks in each mage tree has all the
schools of magic being illusion
conjuration destruction restoration and
alteration
while also housing and chanting this is
easily the one for mage users as it's
right in the name the warrior tree has
the skills of smithing
heavy armor block two-handed one-handed
in archery for those who enjoy combat
but prefer it up close with raw steel or
a distance with an arrow
the thief tree is the last tree with
light armor sneak
lock picking pickpocket speech and
alchemy nine times out of ten this tree
will most likely be with other
trees like the warrior and the mage tree
but as a standalone it still can work
pretty great giving you the edge on
sales with its barter skills and the
ability to get money with less work by
stealing and looting while also staying
hidden so no one can see you with your
light armor
if you happen to be in a pinch alchemy
provides the player with tons of unique
and specific potions for every encounter
like increased carry weight harder for
more money or needing to turn invisible
it's always been a toss-up for me why
alchemy enchanting and archery are in
their respective places as they can kind
of go in the middle between both trees
that they're in
archery can be both in the warrior and
thief tree as being stealthy and
shooting from the shadows is practically
hand in hand
enchanting works with warriors as
enchanting makes your weapon more
powerful and with alchemy making potions
and being a mage usually go hand in hand
as well
so these are kind of like the middle
ones that can go in either tree and i
think that's why they're split between
the two
and these different perks can be really
powerful generic spells at a novice
level are weak but
using master level spells is a whole
other story smithing can make you go
from this to
this and sneak can just completely
confuse everyone of course while they
are in separate trees that doesn't mean
you have to stick with one tree skyrim
of course encourages using things from
all three you could be a two-handed
warrior with full heavy armor and then
use that intimidation to level up your
speech skill getting better prices or
use enchanting to further their power or
you could just be everybody's favorite
stealth archer and that's in no way a
jab at stealth archery either combining
both sneak and archery allows for six
times the damage off a sneak attack and
the enemy doesn't know where you are as
you're 30 feet away on the top of a
cliff
if using a real bow isn't your style
conjuration can help you summon one
coupled with the rolling mechanic
different arrow types and the slowing of
time to land the perfect shot
it's no wonder that this game becomes a
breeze with this build and that's the
other part of combat skills there's a
plethora of skills
according to the game's wiki there's a
total of 251 across all the 18 perks
there's a ton of variety that comes with
this as well as making the game
constantly replayable
some people when it comes to build do
the general types arch mage thief
warrior but some might go the extra mile
and do specific sections to their
character like our previous example we
have a two-handed heavy armor-wearing
character who is so strong that he
believes that he can intimidate people
just by his mere presence making his
speech skill and barter skill leagues
above the rest and that's just one of
the many builds you can create you can
combo together pretty much anything to
make a build that works properly giving
you an infinite number of options as the
game encourages this with replayability
and access to each of the trees and
nothing more solidifies this point in my
opinion than redwater den
and yes i understand that i'm bringing
this place up again and it'll be brought
up again later in the dlc but
just shortly as there is one instance
that is super eye-opening if you don't
remember from when we last brought this
up in redwater den by drinking their
skuma you then pass out and are locked
in a cage well the game provides you
with multiple ways to get out and some
are better depending on your build we're
gonna be doing this with three separate
characters and for the sake of an
example let's just assume they're all
specked in one of each of the trees
one mage one thief and one warrior for
the warrior character he wants to fight
his way out instead of dealing with the
trivial nature of locks and sneaking so
he can either swing his sword and hit
the guard or use an arrow to shoot him
through the cell provoking him and
opening the door anyway if the weapons
won't work of course a shout will do the
trick the thief likes to deal with
things quietly and sneakily so the thief
can opt to pickpocket the guard allowing
him to open the cell from the inside or
if that's too easy pick the lock
themselves and open the cell door that
way and even if they fail the pickpocket
the guard will end up noticing and
getting aggro to them opening the cage
anyway so it doesn't matter the mage has
many options
as well he can offer both styles of play
want a fight immediately throw a
fireball to piss off the guard if you
want to do things lazily you could just
summon an atronach to do it for you or
if they prefer the quiet magic there is
a telekinesis book inside the cell they
can use to hover the key over that is 9
ways to escape this cell and there is
tons more depending on the level of your
character
lesser level characters have more
limited options as the proficiency with
things aren't as high or high level
characters can get pretty creative this
is just one of the many options the
player has throughout the game skyrim
doesn't cut certain things off when it
comes to certain situations
skarm allows the player to actually use
different items and abilities and
encourages that throughout the whole
game while of course you aren't in a
cell a majority of the game when you are
doing majority of the game
is fighting the game perfectly displays
all three bars necessary at the bottom
of the screen to let you know how empty
or full one is so you can act
accordingly instead of making the shout
another bar they remove the clutter by
putting it at the top of the compass
overall the combat and skills in skyrim
are always fantastic and it makes it
actually worth the effort to go out and
purchase those spell books craft that
new armor enchant those new weapons and
speak with others as
not only do you level up so you can
increase your skills further in the game
it provides you with the tools to do
these previously mentioned tasks and
then gives you a playground to use your
newly made ideas and abilities allowing
for endless content and constant
replayability as tackling the same quest
but with different skills allows for
fights and engagements to be a different
experience
this couple with the many side quests
the game has is without a doubt one of
the main reasons people return to the
game
even after 9 years of course gameplay is
just one of the many unique things you
can use as a selling point
some use its unique and original
mechanics to encourage players to have a
new experience and
it can also be the potential of not only
enjoying the game but a couple buddies
as well
and personally my favorite a
well-structured and significant
storyline
if you want players to care about the
story make them care about it having
someone die in the first five seconds of
the game is meaningless than if we spent
the whole game with them
learning about them and being partners
with them of course this is on a
case-by-case basis
as some games have made that very
immediate death work out really really
well
regardless the point still stands if the
developers don't care about the story
then the players shouldn't either that's
why skyrim while not exactly an original
idea of having this overpowered main
character
the other implications skyrim has makes
the story all the more worth it
the other scrolls as a series has been
going on since the mid 90s with elder
scrolls arena in 1994. the main writers
for the series got their inspiration
from old style pen and paper
role-playing games like d and d
while arena didn't have many elements of
story to start out with with each new
iteration of a series new story pieces
would be introduced like locations
politics religion and tons more until
they had a fully fleshed out world with
a cohesive storyline
skyrim story starts out in the back of a
cart with no idea who you are
where you are what you're doing and how
you got there loads of questions and no
answers there are three other people in
the same cart with you
someone in rags and two others that look
like they have armor or at least there's
some part of organization or group one
of those two men has his mouth bound so
he can't speak
on your way to your unknown destination
you can learn a bit more about them the
man driving the cart seems to be an
imperial and is part of the empire the
two in blue are stormcloaks and it seems
like these two are in some sort of
confrontation of war and they happen to
be caught as prisoners
us and the other man are low-keyer and
are just criminals who don't really
belong and somehow got mixed up with
this war criminal stuff going on
once making it to the destination you're
able to select your character and this
is purely customization except the race
which has small benefits but in the
grand scheme of things really doesn't
mean much
each race has different leveled skills
the default minimum number for a skill
is 15 but each race has 5 skills that go
to 20 and one at 25. each race also has
one power and one racial trait
if the previous section about the combat
and skills of the game was any
indication
it's that while a bonus to choose a
proper race to match the style of your
character
is cool it's not entirely necessary a
little bit later
the game practically teases you as the
moment you choose your character
you're almost instantly killed the
moment you're about to be executed
though a dragon steps in and intervenes
either knocking over or distracting
everyone long enough for you to escape
you then run to safety while being
chased by a dragon at every turn really
showing the true power that the dragons
have
eventually after some time you'll make
your way out of the cave and that's
where the game truly starts as we stated
previously you don't really understand
the whole plot of the game until you get
a little bit further
once you do help out the yarl of white
run he instructs you to assist him
in killing the dragon at a nearby
watchtower upon defeating him you then
learn that you can consume dragon souls
one of the guards says it's an ancient
gif passed down to very few people known
as the dragonborn then a loud voice
erupts over the world and the yarrowlist
unto hear that you're dragonborn as
there hasn't been one since the last era
which means the prophecies of alduin
returning to destroy the world are true
and coming back
the story of skyrim all started back in
the murific era
ages ago when the dragon war was ensued
three people
faldir hakan and gormaliath fought
alduin atop the throat of the world in
an attempt to end the dragon war they
were unsuccessful at first so faldir
turned to the elder school as a last
resort and created what's called a time
wound by sending all the wind to a
different time
and in specific our time in the fourth
era it might not make sense how he sent
him further in time as opposed to back
in time but that's what time wounds do
in the murific era the war on dragons
was called the dragon war but now that
it were in the fourth era
this is now known as the dragon crisis
the crisis and the rise of the
dragonborn has been prophesied for years
and people believe the end of the world
would soon come
and the dragonborn is absolutely
necessary to going against this prophecy
assuming the people of skyrim band
together and fight a dragon they can
kill it and within their mortal lives
it'll most likely never come back to
life but
in some different era years away it'll
come back alive again and the cycle will
repeat which is why the dragonborn is
considered the ultimate dragon slayer as
it can take the soul that lays dormant
inside the bodies of the dragon so it
can never be resurrected again towards
the end of act one is where this
information is really starting to come
together as the first two or three
missions are just blended in tutorials
the player eventually meets the
greybeards a group of people who sit
atop the throat of the world and are
masters of the thumb simply talking or
even whispering can cause avalanches and
dangerous weather which is why they
don't speak
arm gear is the only one of the
greybeards that has learned to control
his doom which is why he's only able to
talk to you i'm unsure if that's
represented by the fact that out of the
four grey beards three of them don't
have tied beards and the one who does is
armor but maybe i'm just looking too far
into this regardless the graveyards
basically tell you right away you are
the person who will save the world
kind of a heavy burden but you got to do
what you got to do when you're part of a
prophecy but we are done with
introductions as the greybeards will
send you on a mission to retrieve the
horn of jurgen windcaller which is the
founder of the greybeards a long time
ago
upon arriving the horn is gone but a
note is left that says we need to meet
the person who wrote the note at an inn
doing as the instructions say introduces
us to delphine who works at it in but is
also secretly part of an organization
called the blades that
has been an organization for quite some
time going back to around the first era
when they were originally called the
dragon guard
after the oblivion crisis of the third
era and the great war which is roughly
around year 177 of the fourth era
is when the number was rapidly declining
thanks to the aforementioned events the
great war and the oblivion crisis the
only members that exist now are delphine
and esburn since they are part of the
blades they take on the same role as the
other blades did back in the first era
now which is to hunt the dragons and
more specifically protect the dragonborn
delphine says to meet at kind's grove as
there's a dragon burial site located
there and upon arriving the player then
discovers how alduin is doing all this
with the resurrecting of the dragons he
is literally rebirthing them back to
life killing this dragon proves to
delphine that you are indeed the
dragonborn you've been telling her about
and that the next step of the plan is to
figure out how the hell all this is
happening and that she thinks that
falmore embassy is behind the connection
to the dragons the thelmer have always
been very mysterious and confusing but
in terms of what they do in skyrim
specifically they try to root out all
worship of talos they sent on kano a
thalmor agent to study the college and
constantly try to keep the civil war of
skyrim at a stalemate so they can clean
up the scraps of the war and third party
them
they also waged a crusade against the
blades and almost wiped all of them out
so they're not exactly the nicest people
regardless after sneaking into the
embassy it's clear that the thalmor are
not behind the dragons coming back but
they do have intel on the other blade
members that are left delphine and this
new person esburn who we have not seen
yet asburn seems to be hidden away in
the rataways of rifton which means we
have to go there to see what he's all
about
asburn is definitely a paranoid man at
first judging by the amount of locks on
his door he's not exactly looking to be
caught
but he is extremely educated on the
dragon crisis of skyrim and
also predicted the returning of alduin
as he's been monitoring the ancient
prophecies for
quite a while ezran speaks of an area
that houses a large mural which depicts
several key future events this has
things like the oblivion crisis the
civil war
alduin and tons of more significant
events in the history of tamriel even
though this was constructed in the first
era those previously mentioned events
happened
centuries later this is located in
skyhaven temple it's basically a
decommissioned base but it used to
belong to all the members of the blades
but since there's only two now there's
lots of empty unused space
when reading the mural it depicts all
the one being defeated by a shout
meaning there is some specific shout
that can
take him down so it's back to the
greybeard to instruct you to meet their
mentor parthenax
a giant dragon who's lived on top of the
throne of the world since the marithic
era parthenox was a part of alduin's
team of dragons he was a lieutenant of
sorts but he and a few others betrayed
him as part the next claimed it was
because he could sense a lot of false
godhood that drove alduin down the wrong
path i've always loved parthenox as a
character and he's definitely in the top
three for characters in this game he's
realized the error of his ways very
early on in his life and has decided to
turn it around as a dragon for those who
don't know you have this insatiable urge
to just dominate people and
wreak havoc across the world but since
he's arrived in skyrim back in the
marithic era he's stopped these urges
through meditation
it's always pissed me off that you have
to kill him because what exactly has he
done wrong since the marithic era
technically it's not exactly required to
finish the game but if you happen to
partake in this quest both options do
suck either you kill parthenox and the
gray bridge disown you or you keep him
alive and you can't exactly finish any
of the blade's quest lines which is
easy dragon soul hunting i've never been
able to wrap my head around why they
care so much but it all makes sense as
they kind of kill all the dragons and
they can't exactly keep one alive just
because we say that they're nice but i
mean the blade's whole shtick is to make
sure that the dragonborn is protected
and follow him so if the dragonborn says
that he doesn't want to kill parthenax
who exactly are they to judge
personally if parthenox can calm his
urges and not kill everyone for multiple
eras through meditation then i think
he's not a threat to anybody parthenex
does reveal to the dragonborn though the
shout that defeated alduin and that was
called dragonrend in order to find this
we have to go back in time using an
elder scroll to see the flashback of the
three warriors we previously mentioned
and hear how they set the shout this
requires you to start at the college of
winterhold where they then instruct you
to go to septimus's hideout where he
points us to a dwarf in ruin once you
progress through the whole ruin you then
make it to blackreach a massive
underground dwemer city you take the
elevator and then you arrive at the
alakiri operation there is a puzzle that
is required to open it but it is fairly
understandable and once completed you
open the capsule that houses the elder
scroll that was about an hour and 30
minutes worth of walking and fighting
that we summarized in about four
sentences
it's a really long quest going back to
the throat of the world you can open the
elder scroll and watch the flashback to
learn dragonrend conveniently all the
one arrives shortly
after so you get to test out the new
shout out even alduin fight atop the
world just like the previous adventurers
did
except he leaves when you lower his
health enough now it's time to go on the
offensive as he's trying to regain his
power
to get there we need to challenge a
dragon at dragon's reach as they always
love a challenge
and will never back down from one except
the only place to capture one of course
is dragon's reach and jarl walgriff is
not exactly happy with having a dragon
in his reach
even though that's the main reason for
that keep at the bottom the other reason
is also due to the fact that there's an
ongoing war and seeing as he's right
dead in the middle of two factions it's
understandable that this is probably not
a good look for him you can either
attempt to negotiate a peace treaty or
waste about one to two hours doing
repetitive tasks and win the war for
either side
once one of those two options is
complete you can then capture the dragon
at dragon's reach who is odawing this
dragon will now serve you as you prove
that you're thumb
to be better and says that alduin has
fled to sovereign guard and the only way
to get there is through skull defend
temple which is only accessible by
flying to him you're not really coming
back so
make sure you're all stocked up because
this is a fairly large area with draugr
dragons and dragon priests once you jump
into the portal it can take the player
to sovereign guard alduin has retreated
here so he could devour the nord heroes
and regain some strength in sovereign
guard is the hall of valor where many of
history's greatest warriors are here
including ysgramor
jurgen windcaller the foreman y'all of
whiterun olaf onei and
many many more most importantly though
houses the three warriors from the
flashback hakan felder and gormoliath
those three in the dragonborn then set
out to the front of the gates across the
bridge and battle alduin in an epic
final showdown
defeating alduin rids the world of his
darkness and completes the prophecy as
well as living up to your destiny as the
dragonborn this final scene has always
been iconic to me and something that
will never leave my mind
being able to do battle with the same
three who defeated him previously was
always a small but fantastic touch to
the quest
sovereign guard is also just a gorgeous
set piece for the final quest and the
amount of people in this building that
are just well respected that you can
meet and talk with before doing battle
is just always great to hear especially
since most of them know who you are and
are eager to see you in sovereign guard
when your time comes which is pretty
touching no wonder the nords constantly
talk about sovereign guard if this is
what the afterlife is like i'll be very
much looking forward to it like they do
being able to drink and eat all day
constantly without end and not worrying
about the stresses of everyday living
while being beside some of the most
fantastic people in the world sounds
like an absolute blessing and that's the
exact message of the hall
of valor was trying to convey skyrim's
story is one that i'm always going to
remember
yes it had the typical main character
power fantasy shtick that many stories
have but it builds upon that power in a
unique way people in skyrim know what
dragonborns are as we're not the first
and we most likely won't be the last so
it's not some weird crazy one-off
occurrence that has never existed in
this world we aren't just overpowered
with no reason as to why
but having all that power makes the game
just more fun in tv shows and movies
when we see someone with overpowered
strength we envision what would happen
if we were them in their shoes
constantly making our own choices
except it's a film so the choices have
already been made out and we can't
change anything
in skyrim they give you that same power
give you the envisioning to make any
choice you want and let you roam free
meaning we can be that overpowered
person we've always envisioned but
actually make our choices
mean something this time and not just
something in our head which is why i
think it fits perfectly into this game
although it's fair to assume most enjoy
the side quest more than the actual
story itself regardless it's not a
complete drag to complete and has some
excellent story elements that get new
players extremely invested in the
history of the game
but the main quest isn't the only thing
capable of intriguing the player
side quests may be too short as some can
be finished in over 20 minutes where the
main quest may be seen as too long or
not interesting enough skyrim's secret
backup plan is factions there are loads
of factions that dragonborn could be a
part of some small and some large but
for the purpose of this video we'll be
discussing five particular ones the
college of winterhold the companions
thieves guild dark brotherhood and the
civil war opted to put both the
stormcloaks and the empire in one
section as it's obvious they are both at
war so both sides will be covered in the
civil war section of the video anyway
there are three honorable mentions that
being the bard's college the covenant of
nemira and the york strongholds each of
them are good in their own specific way
but they require at least one quest to
be fully completed so it never really
felt like a true mini story just
a small side quest and none of them are
really bad either all three of them are
great but when you look at it compared
to the others we'll be discussing they
don't even
compare in story gameplay and overall
reward for the end goals the bart's
college has you become a bard nymira's
coven turns you into a cannibal and the
bloodkin makes you friends with orcs and
the strongholds
i feel bad not mentioning these at all
as their entertaining quest but
certainly didn't want to dedicate many
pages to it so this will work as a
compromise four out of the five factions
in skyrim that we'll be discussing are
associated to specific styles or combat
the dark brotherhood is mainly for
assassins the thieves guild is for
thieves the college of winterhold is for
mages and the companions is more of a
grab bag of sorts but
can be used to obtain werewolf status
there are no prerequisites to joining
these factions while being a mage is
helpful for the college questline it's
not a large requirement the character i
made through this playthrough as
mentioned before is heavily specced in
one-handed and heavy armor so
technically i should be as far away from
the college the dark brotherhood and the
thieves as humanly possible yet i still
joined and completed their questline
meaning the styles each one leans
towards aren't required but are helpful
for those who want to fit that kind of
narrative style
a thief character would clearly want to
join the thieves guild as soon as
possible as the rewards can make their
character way better most of their
awards received from these questlines
didn't help my one-handed heavy armor
imperial as he didn't really fit with
what the quests were about like i said
that doesn't mean i can't do them but if
i played a thief character i'd
definitely get more out of the thieves
skill quest line than my one-handed
character would but the fact that i can
attempt these and still complete them
makes these factions and skyrim all the
more great because i'm not bound to a
specific playstyle from the beginning of
the game i can choose to change whenever
i want to even though i had very little
in light armor i still put on the
thieves guild and the dark brotherhood
armor as not only did it make sense to
match with the current faction i was
doing the questline for the armor had
enchantments that helped the quest so
even my heavy armor character was still
able to sneak around thanks to the armor
each faction not only has unique styles
they lean towards but also a unique
questline this usually ends up making
the dragonborn the leader in some way
for all the factions usually start out
as some sort of initiate doing small
contracts like a simple killing or
beating someone up afterwards you're
then given a more tougher contract like
stopping operations in the golden glow
estate or killing someone of a higher
stature like a politician or noblewoman
obviously having to kill three people
back to back isn't much fun but since
they're in different locations the style
of the kill is a lot different
with one assassination you could be in
an open field so creeping up next to
them shouldn't get you caught but you'll
definitely not be caught if you do a
ranged attack the other could be located
in a city so an up-close encounter may
get you caught which means you may have
to only be able to do ranged attacks
making the engagement a bit more
interesting of course doing the same
thing after a while can get very boring
so that's when the factions turn to
their huge turning points each of the
factions have a fantastic storyline that
starts from these specific turning
points within their respective stories
the dark brotherhood starts when a
jester arrives called cicero and he
starts rambling on about terms like
night mother and listener this then
evolves into the soon-to-be final
contract for the falkraith sanctuary
where the brotherhood is tasked with
killing the emperor of tamriel
it takes even more turns as people's
feelings get involved and people end up
betraying you so the whole sanctuary is
attacked and burned but regardless of
the circumstance the contract is still
up
and you as the listener have to do the
one-man job and assassinate the emperor
of course many steps were taken before
this we were first tasked with killing a
noble woman on her wedding day in the
heart of solitude this can either be
done using a bow or collapsing the stone
then we have to kill a guy named the
gourmet and impersonate him in an
attempt to poison the emperor it ended
up being a ruse as then the sanctuary is
attacked and everyone but a couple
members lives it turns out that astrid
talked with the empire and attempted to
sell us out so that they would leave the
brotherhood alone
even though almost everyone in the
brotherhood is dead the contract is
still up and we're the listener so it
needs to be fulfilled we end up finding
out that the emperor is located on a
ship called the kataraya which is docked
in the east empire company near solitude
the boat is filled with penatus
aquilatus guards all armed and ready to
defend the emperor which we need
to get through before we get to the
emperor himself when we arrive the
emperor doesn't put up a fight as he
knows what we are here for and what
we're going to do and is content with
that outcome
so we end his life ending the quest line
the thieves guild has always been
intriguing to me as it's a group based
around
thieving just the idea has kind of
always fascinated me you get to go a lot
more in depth with the people of this
faction as some others although i think
the companions go the furthest in depth
but
we'll get into that later you meet many
people roon vex
sapphire mercer delvin and brinyoff
among a host of others who are all
unique in their own way
mercer is the current guild master vex
is a master locksmith sapphire used to
be part of the dark brotherhood but
since left to join the thieves guild and
rune's story is
actually a quite of a mystery that no
one has really figured out yet all of
these culminate into this lively area of
people that make it feel real the
thieves guild has the cistern where the
vault and equipment are for the thieves
who want to brush up on some skills then
they all meet in the ragged flagon for
some drinks and food when they want to
relax the dark brotherhood was also
pretty lively as well but it sometimes
felt that you would only walk in the
very beginning area
talk to astrid and leave without really
talking to anyone when the ragged flag
and it's hard not to talk with someone
as most of the guild is relaxing there
for the story the thieves guild has been
having some monetary issues as they
haven't been doing too well in their
recent raids which is where the
dragonborn comes in to help them get
them back on their feet
everything goes haywire as brinyoff
mentions the possibility of a traitor
attacking the guild after finding some
info you discover it's an ex-member
named carliah so you and mercer go to
snowville sanctum to confront her like
the emperor assassination though it's
ulrus and
mercer was the actual villain and
traitor all along he was the one who
killed the previous guild master and
framed a carliah for it he ended up
chasing mercer down by finding his final
battle plans which are to steal the eyes
of the falmer from a dwarven ruin which
are some of the rarest items
in the game this then ends in a
one-on-one battle between you the
current guild master and
mercer the former guild master some have
claimed this is the end of the questline
but technically you go a little bit
further as from a thieves go perspective
you are finished but considering that
you became a nightingale halfway through
the story there is still a mission to do
which is to take the trial and
prove your worth to the daedric prince
nocturnal both the thieves guild and the
dark brotherhood are similar in that
they've had betrayal happen to them
which sets off a chain of unfortunate
events and both factions engage in
illegal work but of course they do
differ in style and slight alterations
in their betrayal storylines which makes
both of them just all the more fun
lots of people who either say these are
the two best factions in the game or at
least have one of these in their top two
these two are easily the most superior
in content story reward and overall
immersion like i said the cistern and
the ragged flag and make it feel like
people are actually there doing
different things and not just sitting
around being generic npcs it actually
feels really lively and that's not of
course to say that the next two aren't
bad as that's just false and honestly
some of their qualities rival or surpass
the previous two when part of a guild
you need to be able to trust people
trust is absolutely key to getting the
mission done smoothly and quickly
and while the previous two factions have
that nothing really surpasses the trust
of the companions in this regard when
you think of companions you think of
brothers
sisters partners and family and those
are all correct and what the companions
are they address each other as shield
sister and shield brother and are
constantly mentioning how they are a
family the companions have no leader
while a harbinger does exist they are
only there to handle disputes resolve
issues or clarify questions other than
that everyone is on a leveled playing
field no one has authority over others
which is emphasized in their name
companions a group of people who share
the similar ideals without a leader it's
clear this faction is one of the more
nicer and legal ones as they are first
seen fighting a giant declared from a
farm this is an example of them helping
the residents of the town
the other is in the radiant quests every
faction has radiant or repeatable quest
the player can do
and those radiant quests for the
companions are lawful and nice quests
beating up someone who's harassing
another citizen or clearing vampires
from a cave the companion's home base is
your vascular and white run and it's
almost just as alive as the thieves
guild is upon entering the first two
seconds there is already a fight you can
watch between the two members
outside is where the companions hone
their skills and where the group's
blacksmith works inside is the dining
hall big enough to fit everyone and
while yes the cistern has tables as well
it feels like whoever's at the table is
going to be conversing with those at the
table not so much as alternating but
when there's one giant table everyone is
involved within the conversation
lastly of course is the basement where
the group sleeps and you'll find most of
the members in here the companions quest
line takes a turn when you're introduced
to the circle
small section of the companions are a
part of the circle and as they claim are
in touch with their hunting ability and
that's why they're werewolves there has
been some debate on whether being a
werewolf is the morally right choice for
its members but remember
nobody has authority which is why
there's a mix of werewolves and
non-werewolves within the faction
this quest line is sadly one of the
shorter ones taking roughly two hours to
fully complete but within those two
hours you learn so much about your
vascular inhabitants that it feels like
you were playing for hours
ayla and her family bloodline have been
companions for years so it's only
natural she joined too
cadillac is the harbinger but is also
one of the wisest in the group and
vilkas and farkas are twin brothers who
have been with the guild since the very
beginning as they're considered one of
the youngest and one of the first
members of the guild itself the quest
line comes to an end when the companions
are raided by the silver hand
a rival group to the companions they
attack the hall and slay cadillac and
steal the muthrad fragments so you chase
them down to find the rest of the
fragments
after finding them you assemble wu
thread back to its original shape and
place it in the hands of viscera more
and yes gomorrah's statue at his tomb so
you can meet cadillac's ghost and
cleanse him of his lycanthropy cadillac
has always
believed that his lycanthropy was
holding him back from entering sovereign
guards so to give him peace in the
afterlife we have to defeat his werewolf
spirit which you can do by throwing the
glenmore witch head into the fire and
killing the spirit once killed this
gives cadillac the peace he deserves and
he can now rest in sovereign guard with
everyone else
all these groups in one way or another
are factions groups of people either
held together by a leader or not but all
share the same values
but what the college does is it's just
that a college
they don't fight for peace or coin
they're just a college and just like a
college everyone has different beliefs
most of the npcs in the past factions
we've talked about have some sort of
quest you can do but all of them are
somehow
related to the faction in one way the
quests from the students at the college
are more personal is argo and birth name
both have spells they want to test out
on you which you happen to be the dummy
for whether that means they use the
spell on you or you use it on other
people the college does have many parts
there is the courtyard which is the main
hub connecting the three different halls
the last two are where the students
reside depending on their seniority and
skill while the hall of elements houses
the lecture hall and the arcaneum which
is the college library housing books all
the way from back to the second era the
turning point of this questline starts
very early when you take a trip to an
abandoned [ __ ] when you come across a
giant glowing orb of magic this then
turns even more crazier as a member of
the so-called psijic order talks about a
predetermined chain of events that will
occur and that it's our job to stop it
when it happens which as we discover is
the betrayal of von kano as he planned
to gain knowledge of this orb to help
the thaumor embassy only by using the
staff of magnus can we prevent him from
doing such a thing and put an end to
this chaos the college of winterhold
while fun hasn't really been something
i've always gravitated towards given my
nature to enjoy steel over spells
but this faction is a mage's dream
giving them unlimited possibilities
and making them stronger in the process
you would think as a college you'd be
able to learn spells and gain more
knowledge and you'd be absolutely
correct as not only can you find books
which permanently increase your spell
skill but some of the teachers can teach
you master versions of spells with each
teacher having a different school of
magic to train under it's not the
faction i go to immediately every
playthrough but it's one that i
definitely go to at some point is i feel
like if i skip this quest line i'm
missing out on the fantastic story
rewards scenery and
the library the colleges it's all unique
in all those ways the thing with all
four of these is that you don't really
know about them until someone either
mentions them in conversation or you
somehow come across them the first
second of the game is when you figure
out about the war as there are imperials
who are driving the cart and the
stormcloaks are in the cart with us
it's a small interaction where we start
to see the two sides differ these two
sides have their own beliefs politics
and supporters
the imperials believe that because
skyrim is a province of the empire that
it should abide with the empire's laws
and rules while the stormcloaks believe
in a free government away from the
empire and want to secede from them this
is all due to the past war called the
great war which was against the imperial
legion and the aldmeri dominion which is
an army of elves who believe in
supremacy over all beings with the elves
being the leaders the elder married
dominion dominated the legion and had
them accept terms of surrender it's
because of this that the stormcloaks
think that they are puppets to their
cause
it's completely up to the dragonborn to
choose who they want and why they want
to whether it's based on morals values
or you like one color over the other the
civil war of skyrim while not the best
of the faction quest in the game is
still a great questline as it has
constant conflict with the imperials and
stormcloaks being everywhere in the game
it allows the player to be influenced by
anything it has been a huge debate on
which side is more beneficial to skyrim
as a whole because not only do we have
to take into account the numbers of
their men and how they structure their
government but the obvious next threat
of the aldemary dominion
the question really comes down to who
you believe is capable of winning or are
none of them capable or and they're just
fighting to be inevitably wiped out
anyway
each side plays out roughly the same
besides minor differences the dragonborn
will go and defeat the opposing side's
forces in numerous camps and fortresses
and holds until they reach the final
battle whether that's in solitude or
windhelm where they charge up the
streets to the main castle and kill the
leader i understand it'd be too long to
code and would definitely be completely
irrelevant now but i always wish that
this was a little bit changed between
the factions even if you're going to
different holds and camps you're still
doing the same process of clearing out
enemies and liberating them adding in
more quests like the jagged crown
portion but
having them be slightly different would
be fantastic something as small as
watching over the new recruits once you
hit a certain rank in the army so it
makes it feel worth it and with elder
scrolls 6 on the horizon it's possible
another war can be visited there too
depending on the era and location of
game of course i hope that that would be
taken into account should they decide to
have a war with in that game as well
everything we've discussed in today's
video so far has been part of the base
game
the music the quest the story the
faction all of it's part of the base
game that came out in 2011 but a year
later in 2012 skyrim will get a new
content in the form of dlcs on june 26
2012
eight months after the release of skyrim
the first installment of downloadable
content was dawnguard bethesda went all
out for this dlc
not only had they made new buildings and
structures that existed within the world
itself but two original areas as well
this is their first dlc for the game so
they had to make sure it was right
dangard's story is a rivalry between the
two groups the don guard and the
volakara castle the dawnguard are an
ancient order of vampire hunters it's
clear where the origins started but some
say around the second era the volakar
clan started with lord harkin when he
pledged himself to the daedric prince
molag bal it's unclear when this
happened as well but since vampires
don't die of old age this could have
easily been around the same time at the
second era or maybe even earlier the
story revolves around the feud between
these two groups and specifically their
plans
the don guard simply wants to wipe out
the vampires but the vampires have a
more sinister plan they plan to purge
the world of sunlight so the vampires
can roam free once more they do in fact
want to kill the dawnguard but the
purging of the sun to them is more
important lord harken is unsure how to
enact this point specifically as the
prophecy is written across three
separate elder scrolls which becomes the
main turning point for the dlc
every dlc has to have some sort of
starting point and dawnguard starts via
asking around like most of the other
quests in the game until
this dialogue is triggered don guard
compared to the future dlc we'll be
getting to a little bit later is a lot
shorter compared to the others and can
be done almost right away at level 10 as
the recommendation you're then taken to
a castle which is for
dawnguard the leader isran thinks that
you have some skill and he wants you to
prove it so he instructs you to dim
hollow crypt to see what the vampires
are up to the crypt as expected is
guarded by vampires towards the end of
the crypto there's some giant device of
some sort in the middle of the room
by moving the braziers we discover it's
a puzzle which when completed opens
something in the middle and that
something
is a woman who's holding an elder scroll
what the [ __ ] this is serana the
companion for the dlc and personally
always been my favorite
she tells us that we need to get back to
her family and then she'll explain
everything when we're there
long story short we find out that serana
is the daughter of lord harkin which
would explain the vampirism lord harkin
thanks you for returning his daughter
and offers you a reward
but as he states the only thing equal of
value to an elder skull and his daughter
is to give you his blood which would not
only make you a vampire
but a vampire lord this decision is
where the game splits from here should
you accept you're introduced to the new
vampire skill tree very similar to the
also newly introduced werewolf skill
tree but
just the vampire one these follow the
same procedures to ranking up to
increase two-handed skills you need to
use two-handed weapons to increase the
vampire skilltree you need to be a
vampire lord and do some damage
denying his request forbids you from
ever entering the manor again and will
force you back to the dawnguard side
while we're at the crossroads let's go
over some of the rest of the content
that is coming with this dlc besides
just a new story and a couple perk trees
dawnguard also introduced dragonbone
weapons which at the time only the armor
existed and these dragonbone weapons are
even more deadlier than daedric weapons
are there's also a new ranged weapon
which is the crossbow mostly used by the
dawnguard order each group also has
their own host of new creatures for
example the dawnguard has armored trolls
who they have trained to fight for them
while the vampires have gargoyles who
stand guard surrounded in stone waiting
to jump out at any unsuspecting visitor
a new plane of oblivion is introduced
and one that is required to go through
no matter what side you choose so i'll
save that for the later part of the
discussion and the other is a person in
the ragged flagon who can change your
appearance
gender and race are locked but facial
tweaks can be altered for a thousand
gold not a whole lot compared to the
other dlc we'll get to but of course
this is their first dlc and it still
came with quite a few new features
back to the decision the game has 12
main quests 10 are done no matter the
option you pick the other two are
depending on the group you choose
although one is technically the same
with some slight alterations which we'll
also explain should the player decide to
refuse the offer they continue from the
dawnguard storyline
their separate part of the quest is
recruiting new members and finding a
moth priest to unlock the secrets of the
other scrolls serana has
except in the blood continues the
vampire storyline which has the player
filled the bloodstone chalice in a place
i definitely haven't mentioned four
times in this video redwater den
and then finding a moth priest to
decipher the elder scrolls serana has
after this the two groups do the same
quests up until the final mission so
we'll start from there the moth priest
gets a slight understanding of the
prophecy but
needs all the three elder scrolls to be
able to decipher all of them
those two being the dragon and the blood
are the only ones are missing the dragon
skull is obtained via the main quest so
if you've already beaten the main quest
this will be in your inventory the other
is with serrano's mother
except no one knows where she went
serrano's mother ran away years ago and
was the only one who sealed off serana
in that tomb so not even serana knows
where she went there is a secret part of
the castle though that has been
abandoned which might lead us to some
clues after where she went
after discovering the secret entrance
going through tons of hallways we arrive
at her lab so to speak where she would
conduct various experiments via the
alchemy stuff surrounded here with the
correct ingredients you can open up the
seal in the middle which takes us to the
other dimension in the new plane of
oblivion the soul care the soul cairn is
where individuals who have been soul
trapped
go it's also ruled by the ideal masters
being assumed to be necromancers who
created this plane of oblivion but are
now non-physical beings that have
transcended the mortal plane
they tend to make deals with lots of
people in here but almost all of them
favor the masters in some way and
usually end up tricking other
participants valerica serrano's mom was
one such participant
but avoided the ideal master's
punishment by hiding in the abandoned
fort behind a magical wall when we meet
her she lets us know more about the
prophecy of the sun and what it all
means
the prophecy is real about purging the
sunlight from the world but to do that
they need the blood of a cold harbor
daughter molag bal's plain of oblivion
is cold harbor people also worshiped
molag for quite a bit
of time on a summoning day the woman
would be offered as a sacrifice and the
ones who survived would be considered
cold harbor daughters serrano and
valerica were both sacrificed and
survived thus making them
cold harbor daughters harken doesn't
know this yet but once he discovers that
he will need a cold harbor daughter's
blood he will most likely kill serrano
if it means completing the prophecy
seeing as valerica has gone off the face
of the earth and in a totally different
plane
serrano is the only option he has
valerica clearly didn't want that to
happen which is why she hid serana then
fled
to the soul cairn herself so that
neither could be used to complete the
prophecy
the best way to stop this prophecy is
for us to take the scrolls ourselves
regardless of what side you choose you
ultimately see harken as the bad guy
anyway and end up traveling here with
serrano so there's really no change at
this
point but to get to the scroll we need
to defeat the keepers which are the
people that locked her in this magical
wall in the first place once the keepers
are dead there's only one guard that's
been watching her this whole time and
that's a dragon called dernavir
once defeated she gives us the elder
scroll and we can go on our way
once we have all the other scrolls in
hand we must head to ancestor glade and
read the scrolls but reading with
preparation is very important as without
the preparation
it can lead to blindness like dexian had
once the preparation is complete and we
read the scrolls were then taken to the
next large area of the game the
forgotten vale which is a large glacial
area deep in the mountains in the
northwest
the weapon required to beat lord harkin
is in this new area and is told to us by
the snow wealth gullibor we can't just
simply take the weapon we have to
complete the trial which is filling a
water jug from various waste shrines
throughout the area then dumping it at
the entrance to the inner sanctum
we then meet the arcurate one of two
snow elves that we know that exist in
skyrim so far the first of course being
gullibor who we saw before we entered
they are curated as a vampire and it's
discovered that he became inflicted with
vampirism during the merithic era and
because uriel his god did not help him
prevent the infliction by curing him he
created the prophecy of purging the
sunlight and hopes it would weaken
uriel's hold on the world if it was
completed and get some revenge
on the god who wronged him we clearly
can't let that happen for a multitude of
reasons so we just defeat him and we'll
take the bow for ourselves we now have
everything we need to confront harken
and fight him but during the fight
harken will bubble up and become
invulnerable for a little bit of time
the bow reads the possibility of that
and stops him in his tracks once fired
allowing him to be attacked again this
section changes depending on the faction
if it's the dawn guard you side with and
you march up the castle with all the
dawn guarding kill all the vampires
including harkin but if you're part of
the vampires you simply just walk into
the back room then confront them
yourself if you're a vampire and lord
harken is defeated you now become the
vampire lord of the clan as the dawn
guard you just slay everyone and go back
to fort donggaard ending the questline
the main story of dawnguard is pretty
great i've always liked how the ending
is the same regardless of the faction as
it's really the true ending and killing
harken absolutely needed to be done
and of course getting serana as a
companion for both sides has always been
a huge plus
once the main faction is done the player
can do a host of radian quests and other
side quests that are part of the dlc
if with the vampires killing the rest of
the dawnguard is actually a side quest
after the main story is finished there's
also two side quests in the soulcare and
should the dragonborn want to do that
and my personal favorite exploring the
ancient dwarven ruin for the lost
ethereum forge
overall the main quest could take about
two to three hours with other side
quests maybe another two to three hours
either way making this an enjoyable six
hour dlc
the second dlc was released on september
4th of 2012 which was hard fire a mere
three months after dawnguard released
hearthfire was more of a laid-back dlc
providing the player with immersive
world-building options like purchasing
property and building their house skyrim
has 9 different holes within the game
on launch 5 holds allowed homes to be
purchased within the city until
hearthfire came along which had the
ability to make the homes in three out
of the four leftover holds
leaving winterhold being the only hold
in the game with no player options other
than the college which
technically isn't a home while the main
game had homes
hearthfire introduced homesteads with
homesteads you can live outside a city
but within the hole then
build your house the way you want to
unlike homes which are within the city
walls predetermined interiors and
upgrades were also made with gold
not resources of course the issue is
that it requires lots of gold or
resources to make with these homesteads
the three locations you have are morthal
falcreath and dawnstar with the winstead
manor lakeview manor and hell jargon
hall respectively
to first even get the option to purchase
these homes you must complete a quest or
two from the yarl who upon completion
will reward you with the option to
purchase property which then starts the
building process each home
comes with a chest you should be able to
get the basic version of the house
finished and there you can add the main
hall
a cellar and some additional wings but
those are only the structures as there
is a separate workbench inside each area
so that you can change the inside making
it look like an actual home
the main hall is generally the same per
house the seller is one of the best
additions to the house adding a full-on
blacksmith workshop
chess and all nine divine totems the
wings is where the creativity really
comes into play as there are three wings
in each house with each one having three
options meaning a total of nine options
to choose from or
27 combinations of houses that can be
made issue is once you choose one you
must keep it but thanks to there being
three houses you can choose from
assuming you have the loads of resources
it would take to actually build all
these you can then have the nine wing
options but evenly by the three houses
the west wing has additional bedrooms an
enchanter tower or a greenhouse
the bedroom is good if you plan to adopt
kids the enchanting tower has all your
enchanting needs and a greenhouse is a
good place to either display lovely
flowers or grow some alchemy ingredients
the north wing has the alchemy lab
storage and trophy room
all are fairly self-explanatory alchemy
lab has all the alchemy research anyone
could need
a storage room for all the hoarders of
skyrim and a trophy room to display your
most prominent killings the east wing
has the last three options of an armory
kitchen and library the armory has all
your armor and weapon display needs at
the bottom with an archery target on top
and the library can house all your books
or categorize them seeing as there's
tons of different shelves that come with
this installment the kitchen has tons of
ingredients to make
all sorts of food to take on your
adventures and the library can house all
your books or categorize them seeing as
there's tons of different shelves that
come with this installment
of course the wings function like any
other part of the house where you first
start building the structure and
foundation then go inside and actually
get the more detailed stuff inside
there are also a few exterior options as
well like a stable or garden but each
one gets a unique exterior winstead gets
a fishing hatchery lake view gets a
beehive enclosure and helsh marking gets
a grain mill
besides building structures you can also
hire a steward who will then allow you
to purchase a carriage driver bard and
livestock while not the greatest dlc
compared to the other two hearthfire
still offers an immersive world building
experience that helps make skyrim feel
more real being able to make your house
into what you want and the way they make
you build it makes it feel more
rewarding to the player when it's
finally complete i usually do the
hardfire dlc as soon as possible as
it's personally not something you want
to do at the end of the game unless
you've saved all your resources
assuming you didn't it's best to start
the building process early so by the end
of your playthrough you should be pretty
much almost complete we then come to the
final piece of downloadable content
which was released on december 3rd of
2012
13 months after skyrim's release
dragonborn knowing this was the last dlc
skyrim would receive i'm okay with that
while the series is never going to truly
end this was a nice way to end the
content for the game but that's to
switch things up
instead of dawnguard where it added two
large areas while most of the dlc was
within skyrim dragonborn took us to a
whole new area called soulstime
completely separate from the main game
dragonborn also adds new
everything quests spells shouts weapons
armor and enemies but for now let's
discuss the main story the dragonborn
dlc starts differently compared to
dawnguard instead of asking around town
at some point you're just approached by
the cultists after completing one of the
main story quests these cultists ask her
for the dragonborn and claim that the
true dragonborn merak will soon return
killing the cultists drops their orders
on the ground and you find that they're
located in solsteim
as we discover later mirak is not only a
dragonborn but the first
ever dragonborn who was born in the
muritic era merrick was a dragon priest
back in the day when they were only
human and not a rotting corpse
and came into possession of a black book
which transported him to apocrypha where
he met hermaeus mora the daedric prince
of knowledge hermes mora gave mirak the
power of shouts
mirak then used this power to turn on
his dragon masters and became even more
powerful
after some time he was then sent back to
apocrypha and has stayed there ever
since
waited until he amassed enough power so
he could escape the realm and return to
soulstime which is why those cultists
mentioned mirak returning these black
books as we know teleport the player to
apocrypha but at the end of each section
the player can pick certain buffs as a
reward for making it through the dungeon
first we need to find out where mirak is
located and the closest thing we have is
his temple at the end of his temple is a
black book which just like with him we
have to read it we then teleport to
apocrypha and meet the man himself he
says that once his temple is fully built
he'll return but we're clearly not going
to let that happen
at the temple we meet a woman named
freya who helps us by escorting us to
her village and having a speak with the
town shaman he says we must learn the
words to the bend we'll shout as that
will get the people of soulstime out of
this possession that they're in the
shout is located in sereng's watch from
a word wall
after discovering that it works now it's
time to collect the other two and defeat
mirak which means we need to find
another black book which is encased in
some sort of dwarven device
fond returning with the black book and
the second word hermaeus morris says
that we can learn the third fairly
quickly
just we need to spill some secrets on
the skull that village we talked about
we clearly don't know any of the secrets
but the skull do of course and are
hesitant at first to mention anything
but the shaman is willing to die for it
as long as mirek is defeated hermes more
than kills the shaman then gives us the
final word with all three words we could
finally travel to apocrypha
and fight mirak which all happens at the
summit of the apocrypha this is easily
one of the most beautiful boss zones
i've ever seen in this game
mirak challenges you with all of his
different abilities and constantly
regains power and health by consuming
his own dragons midway through the fight
but of course we're too strong for him
and we defeat mirak
now the only one of our kind that we
knew of is now gone and dead at the
hands of his master but on the plus side
soulstein in the world is saved the
ending award is pretty solid in terms of
quantity we get dragon scales and bones
from the dragons he killed we get
mirak's armor we get the dragon souls he
took from us and the ability to respect
all of our skill points at any point in
time from any skill tree and this can be
done infinitely as long as we have the
book waking dreams
i know we just blew by a three hour
story line in what seemed like four
minutes but there's many things this dlc
adds that i want to mention and i prefer
not to do a play-by-play of each of the
dlc story missions especially if you
already understand what happens in it
the story is very similar to dawnguard
and timeline taking around two to three
hours but since it's a new area there's
tons of new and eventful quests to
explore within the dlc
such as thor's call which is a haul
overtaken by the reichlings
you can meet the nords who previously
owned the hall and opt to join them and
take me back
or you could join the opposing side and
join the reichlings and kill the nords
then becoming the chief of them
out of all the titles the dragonborn is
called i didn't think chief of the
reichlings tribe was something i
expected
dragon barn also has some unique mini
bosses and armor the deathbrand armor is
one of the best light armors in the game
in all of skyrim it starts by finding a
book called death bran which tells the
tale of the legendary death brand armor
and how it was stored away and hit him
for years
the armor is stored in four separate
locations you can find via the map and
once obtained the buffs you receive
are absolutely insane the more pieces of
the armor you equip the better and
assuming you have all four pieces you
can receive water breathing 100 plus
armor rating increase the stamina by 60
points carrying capacity by 40 points
and when dual wielding 100 attacks will
do 40
more damage and that's not even
including the buffs that you might be
adding from the light armor skill tree
easily making this a go-to armor for
light armor users dragonborn also comes
with arguably two of the hardest enemies
in the game the ebony warrior and
karstag
karstag has a whopping 4 000 health when
fighting and the ebony warrior while at
most can have 2 000 it's his abilities
that make him tough throughout the fight
he can use unrelenting force his armor
raises his defense his sword absorbs
health he can cast frost cloak and ebony
flesh to reduce physical damage while
also casting restoration to recover his
health he can also reflect the damage
you deal back to you and even paralyze
you with his bow all this happens
throughout the entire fight for killing
the ebony warrior you can then grab his
armor and a bunch of really cool gems
but the reward for karstag is the
ability
to summon him in any fight you want for
a maximum of three times besides these
there are a ton of other quests to do
like solving a possible assassination of
the counselor
funding a mining operation all for it to
turn terribly wrong
and many more dragonborn is the last dlc
skyrim would receive and while it was
sad to say that would be the last one it
was a fantastic dlc to end the game's
downloadable content dragonborn is
personally my favorite and the best dlc
the game has
as it feels like you're experiencing the
feeling of playing skyrim all over again
just with a new storyline and smaller
map there's still one more downloadable
content if you want to call it that to
mention
although it isn't a full-fledged dlc as
skyrim did however receive a massive
update in 2016
in the form of special edition which was
basically the legendary edition of the
main game coming with all three dlcs
except adding many new graphical
enhancements
special edition also introduced modding
to the console community while it was on
the pc version of special edition as
well
pc players already had access to mods
from dedicated modding websites but xbox
and playstation were never able to
experience that before which was a huge
milestone for the game as this came in
the form of a mod listing in-game
and the creation club a monetized
version of the mods that bethesda deemed
worthy to pay for christian club was and
is still a controversial topic but
conveniently it goes into our next and
final topic of the video arguably the
main reason most players will play
skyrim to this day
mods there are loads of mods that skyrim
has there are so many that i can make a
video based on why mods themselves keep
the players going which i may even
consider doing in the future
but because there's so many mods there's
one for everyone with tons of different
things changing and being made it really
changes skyrim going from something like
this
to this while yes the latter is 2500
mods you can still get some drastic
changes with only a handful
body of life mods like a matter of time
quality map and sky ui
change the ui of the game making sifting
through inventory
looking at the time or browsing the map
a lot more optimal and overall just
visually pleasing
texture mods are anything but scarce in
the modding community making the
textures of the game more vibrant and
eye-catching regardless of its buildings
or even retextures of vanilla weapons
for those who want more gameplay focused
mods and not ones that are graphical of
course those are available like making
changes to existing content like
elemental arrows or adding your favorite
weapon and armor from your favorite
movie or video game
skyrim can be pretty boring alone so
maybe you want to take a new follower
with you and in the form of a fully
voiced npc
alright introduction's done so let's get
to adventuring but with there being
loads of followers it's hard to choose
one which is why mods like ultimate
follower overhaul and others like it all
serve the purpose of not making you pick
one but all the followers you want and
depending on how popular that specific
follower is they may even talk to each
other
hello just thought i'd introduce myself
i'm lucian i am pleased to meet you
my name is inigo pleased to meet you too
and ago
i think we're going to make a great team
i think you get where i'm going with
this i could ramble
for hours talking about the mods that
this game has adding new creatures a
survival mode immersive mods and
anything to make the game just feel more
alive but
we simply just don't have the time so
i'll just talk about some of the ones
that i personally like
after playing skyrim for a while you
tend to gravitate towards the same build
i still can't get away from the
one-handed heavy armor brood and some
can drop the stealth archer so ordinator
by ina changes things up allowing you to
use the same build but overhauling all
the perks in every skill tree going from
the vanilla 251 perks to a new 469
and it's not just adding more perks it's
changing the existing perks on top of
adding more options to pick from in each
skill tree for example the sneak tree
can provide the player with tripwires
smoke bombs and a bottle that makes an
oil show you can light on fire
and of course there are additional perks
to make the aforementioned equipment
even better
the smithing tree isn't just as simple
as making new armor anymore you can now
make dwarven auto cannons or
every time you make a weapon you gain
increased critical strike damage and
reduced incoming damage for the next 30
minutes
every skill tree and ordinator gets
changed making skyrim feel new again as
now you can't go to your normal go to
perks
ordinator gives you some that may be
better than your usual picks or makes
you choose between multiple good options
which makes the playthrough that more
engaging again coordinator can also be
installed mid playthrough so it refunds
your perk points allowing you to put
them into new skills so there's no loss
of progress
but of course there's going to come a
point where you really want to try a new
build but you've either done all of them
or nothing really feels unique so let me
introduce a very unique one to you with
the help of the new mod thunderchild
also by ina
a thunderchild is for the people that
want a more in-depth shout build or to
have a shout-centric character to get
access to these you need to visit high
hrothgar and meditate which is a
mini-game in itself by stopping the
meditation when it's close to zero
too early or too late and you'll fail
when completing the meditation you
receive shouts free of charge without
the need for souls but it's only the
first word
follow the quests given to you
afterwards and you can achieve the
second and third word nearby is cabinets
filled with different robes to wear if
you want to match the style the shots
are all very unique like armageddon
causes fire to rain from the sky or
splinter twins which copies the enemies
and now they have to fight copies of
themselves
most of the shouts don't take too long
to charge either which is nice but some
can definitely be a bit long especially
when using multiple
words both ordinator and thunderchild
provide the player with excellent
alternatives to builds whether they be
new or old builds each one is made to
accommodate and provide you with a new
refreshing experience
as we discussed in the hearthfire dlc
section there are only 8 out of the 9
holes that you can have property in but
it's only one choice what if you dislike
that choice which is why my go-to house
mod
has always been riverside lodge by lupus
78. i've never been a big fan of huge
castles if i don't use all the rooms in
my house what's the point in having all
those large rooms
riverside lodge provides the player with
a load of options kitchen
blacksmith enchanting and alchemy tables
bedroom displays
a sauna and some of the best views i've
ever seen getting the whole city of
whiterun
in frame from your house it's big enough
to be more than a simple house but small
enough to make the rooms actually worth
going in and using but maybe you do like
the original locations of the base game
houses
you just don't like the designs of them
which were the queen of player homes
elio nora comes in
with her breeze home mod not only are
her original house mods fantastic but
her overhauls of some of the vanilla
houses are out of this world
threesome goes from a simple house on
the streets of whiterun to something
that looks like it belongs in solitude
with the rich noble families
bookshelves and chess for all your
equipment display cases for the masks
paragons weapons and armor along with a
totally separate area upstairs for all
the alchemy and enchanting it doesn't
even feel like bree's home anymore going
from a simple two-floor house with some
accessories to this
and it does that all in the right ways
after multiple playthroughs the first
hour or so can get really boring going
from helgen to whiterun to bleak false
barrow and back so you can get some
levels and then finally take on the side
quests
live another life by arthur moore and
unbound by china green elvis are both
alternative start mods that work to
change that
live another life starts you in a cell
after customizing your character yet
approach the statue of mara ahead of you
and are given a dozen options to choose
from ranging from guild member to
noblemen
i chose shipwrecked off the coast and
spawned underwater at the top of the map
past dawn star with nothing then other
than what i could scavenge off the ship
you can still pursue the main quest if
you want to either from hearing people
talk about helgen or taking a trip there
yourself and reading a journal which
transitions right into the riverwood
portion of the main quest but it's
entirely up to the player when they want
to
as the game doesn't force you to do this
right away which gives the player more
time to do the side quests without
having to worry about the main quests at
all
skyrim unbound takes this even further
allowing the player to completely get
rid of the dragonborn status which means
no shouts and possibly no dragon should
you choose that option
it may sound boring but it can give the
player the feel of being a normal
adventurer in the world
if you find it's not fun you can simply
toggle it back on and continue as the
dragonborn and do the main quest as you
please but for people who want to be
more immersed as a specific character
without the power of the dragonborn or
just maybe want to do only sidequests as
a non-dragonborn character
you have the option to do so with live
another life you can choose how you
start or
stronghold maybe a ship but with unbound
you can set your starting equipment
starting location or randomize
everything i ended up randomizing my
entire game and i spawned at the hot
springs near rifton with only fine
clothes in my
bare fist meaning i'm going to have to
steal a couple things to get some decent
equipment if i'm going to survive out
here
both live and other life and unbound
give the player a whole new experience
letting the player choose their own
backstory or letting the game choose it
for them making it harder regardless of
the option they are both different from
the main vindala start so instead of
going from riverwood to right run etc
it's a whole new start with a whole new
strategy on what to do first
everything we've discussed so far in my
opinion makes skyrim fresh but
not everyone will use all the perks from
ordinator or every option and live
another life so
maybe it'll be just a nice detour from
the original skyrim experience but it
doesn't feel new
the next two mods however are not only
truly original they're more unique than
anything we've discussed today and quite
possibly a reflection of how great mods
for skyrim
can be those two are brooma and enderol
bruma is one of the many continent mods
for skyrim created by the beyond skyrim
team they have set out to make the areas
of tamriel a reality within skyrim
brumo is the only one i could play at
the moment but they are currently
working on other lanes too like
morrowind at mora black marsh rocera and
elsewire they're essentially dlc
sized mods for skyrim but enderall made
by sure ai
takes it even further enderall isn't a
dlc or even related to skyrim it's a
whole game with its own unique lore
story landscapes and world
used of mostly skyrim assets with some
slight modifications
it's literally a whole game and did i
forget to mention that both of these are
free
i highly recommend supporting both teams
as the more testers and donors they have
the faster they can produce content so
both of the links to both these mods
will be in the description as well as
every other mod we've talked about in
this section as i want to give credit
where credits do
first up i want to discuss bruma so the
dlc bruma is set in the northernmost
county of cyrodiil
bruma this dlc comes with original music
high quality voice actors seamless
integration with current playthroughs
new weapons armored dungeons enemies
points of interest and over 70 residents
within the county
to access simply travel to the new area
pale pass and give some significance as
to why you should cross like archmage
arbinger or dragonborn once crossed
you're told to go to the city bruma once
you arrive you're done with the force
quest beyond skyrim bruma is more of a
teaser for their bigger project beyond
skyrim cyrodiil
this is because not only is this one of
the many areas that exist in syria
though there is technically no main
quest in bruma at the moment past going
to bruma beyond skyrim wants to create
many provinces in skyrim as well like
morrowind and cyrodiil but instead of
taking years to finish all of it at one
time
they're giving out bits and pieces of
the land for players to test and enjoy
while they work on the full game
to help convey this let's use skyrim and
cereal as a proportional example
bruma is basically one of the holds of
skyrim let's say whiterun if this is the
case then anything we can do or explore
in whiterun is fair game all locations
side quests etc are all available in
whiterun but the other eight holds are
unavailable to travel to because they
don't exist
bruma is like whiterun where project
cyberdeal is like skyrim a soon to be
fully fleshed out world with multiple
locations and holds to travel to roma is
just one of the many areas that are
going to be created and it would be
weird putting the main quest in here as
it's going to both not make sense and be
a cliffhanger anyway so there's no point
to even doing it and that's not to say
not adding the main quest is a bad thing
either because since you're not tied to
the main quest you're free to explore
however you want to and broom is a
bustling county filled with all types of
different personalities
scales of auri l thanks for telling me
that
i'll be sure to tell all my friends put
up posters
even outside of brooma is even more
areas to explore and it can seem a
little intimidating on what to do first
as there's no main quest to hold your
hands so
i just looked at the map looked at an
out of place location traveled and see
what i could find i ended up finding a
really large tower which relates to the
college of whispers one of the biggest
new additions to this area is the ayleid
ruins if you've ever played oblivion or
elder scrolls online these are exactly
as you would expect elite ruins are
typical dungeons the player can
encounter skyrim has dwarven ruins which
are made by the dwemer whereas bruma has
alien ruins made by the ancient elves
there's a decent amount of this within
bruma and they're all very unique one
was overrun by the cult of numira while
on another a ghostly voice kept talking
to me only for it to attack me as i was
apparently trespassing in his lair
these dungeons aren't that simple either
many times i would end up lost with how
non-linear these dungeons were some of
the dungeons in skyrim are pretty linear
and not too hard to navigate but i
didn't experience that in bruma there
was clearly a lot of time putting these
caves in ruins and it's clear that's the
main showpiece for this area with bruma
comes new enemies like different
variants of trolls and wolves to things
like minotaurs and ogres the new enemies
had new items clothing and animations
which really helped it set them apart
there are still similar enemy types that
exist in this game as well like bandits
and necromancers but the bandits don't
wear the typical fur armor as much
instead they go with the new clavonian
armor and the necromancers tend to have
a new face mask that they wear with
their other attire the side quests were
a big positive for bruma as there was
lots of diversity
one had me interview noble so i could
find out where this orcs wife was only
to find out that she was cheating on him
with one of the nobles we interviewed
the other one came abruptly as a woman
asked for my help to retrieve an
heirloom only to find out that i was
being tricked and tasked with giving it
back to her against my will the quest
had four optional objectives killing the
men in front of me
and then three different endings
delivering the heirloom to the woman
turning her in for blackmail or taking
the heirloom from myself which blew me
away with the amount of options that i
was given one thing that kept me
immersed in playing this dlc was the
original soundtrack it has around 60
tracks and music equating to about 3
hours of originally composed music it's
different yet similar to skyrim and that
the idea of what kind of composition
they made is similar but i got a
different tune to match the new area
we're in
cereal clearly has a different feel to
it than skyrim so the music should have
a different feeling and it absolutely
nails that the other element of keeping
the immersion was by far my favorite
which has got to be the voice acting
so many unique personalities and all of
them hit perfectly whether the dialogue
was serious or humorous
[Applause]
[Music]
while bruma would still be good if they
used generic voices or no voices at all
like some other mods it just wouldn't
feel the same as the acting makes the
world feel
real and it doesn't take you out of the
immersion it's a sometimes overlooked
detail but it pays off in the end if
done correctly
according to the credits there are 30
people who made up the voices for aruma
some of whom have some pretty large
credits in gaming such as dragon age
inquisition wasteland 2 and dying light
2.
this is just a taste of brooma and i
highly encourage you to try this mod for
yourself if you have the time i know
it's available on pc and from what i've
heard it might be available on console
but it might be a little hard to find
with the mod menus
if room is going to be a representation
of what the other counties will be like
in the future then i'm very excited to
see the full cereal release it's one of
the most expensive and unique dlc mods
i've played for skyrim in a very long
time and it's clear the devs care about
this mod and have put in the work to
make others like it too we then come to
our final mod which is end roll and as
we
said ender all is a game not a dlc like
bruma
full game and it's recognized as one on
steam as it comes up with its own
achievements and its own store page
and the requirements being the specs and
skyrim needs to be purchased
according to the developers it's roughly
a 30 to 100 hour run time which is
excellent for people looking for fresh
new original content but to keep that
skyrim feel would i be lying to you if i
said that this was skyrim with a new
story cause
it's not under all has certain similar
elements like the three bars at the
bottom and a
tree system but completely flipped most
of the other game's mechanics on its
head
off the start health does not regenerate
meaning you have to pick your fights
wisely and the only way to heal is by
eating food drinking a potion or
sleeping making eating and drinking food
actually really useful
enemies are a lot tougher i played on a
lower difficulty on ender all than i did
on skyrim and i was still getting my ass
beat
the term wolves are stronger in packs
was completely true as i found myself
sitting on top of hal's roofs just to
get away from a pack of them
i found myself also getting caught by
enemies wind-up tacks a lot more often
which instead of shaking my screen
slightly and moving me down a little bit
it actually stopped me from moving and
attacking altogether leaving me open for
more damage
magic and stamina are the two bars that
regenerate but in combat it's slower
than normal when it's out of combat
potions are your greatest ally but they
also aren't instantaneous they heal over
time
if food or potions are out then you can
use light magic which is the game's
restoration magic but
any source of healing in the game causes
arcane fever using too much healing
magic takes a strain on your body which
causes you to get a percentage of arcane
fever
too much and you start to lose some
stats and attributes other forms of
magic are fine to use it's just the
healing one to cure this arcane fever
you can either smoke some p-sweet to
calm the nerves or if you need to fix it
faster use some ambrosia but ambrosia
can cost you around 20 gold per bottle
so save some coins for it speaking of
that the skills have been renamed and
changed combat has now been split from
workmanship
most of these are pretty
self-explanatory but to explain the ones
that are a bit more complex to
understand simply psionics is illusion
magic elementarism is destruction magic
mentalism is alteration
entropy is conjuration and light magic
is restoration for the worksmanship tree
handicraft is smithing and rhetoric is
speech and barter these sounds simple
but of course these skills go very far
in depth and they're not just as simple
as a class of magic ranking these up
isn't as simple either instead of using
a specific action described in the skill
tree name enough times like hitting
somebody and leveling up your one-handed
leveling these up is only done by
finding books that are of the correct
proficiency than reading them these can
either be looted off people or bought
from various vendors so not only do you
need to keep gold for ambrosia but also
the books too for worksmanship books
they require the book and the available
crafting points and the combat tree
requires the book and available learning
points so if you want to increase your
two-handed skill from 15 to 16 you're
gonna need a learning book that is
labeled two-handed and then use a
learning point to read it but i can tell
you're a little bit curious as if we
can't level up skills how do we level up
and where do we get the points from well
it's just old-fashioned xp killing
enemies rewards xp just like any typical
rpg
once you level up you're in a set amount
of learning points and crafting points
and memory points per level
memory points are those skill points for
the skill trees this is done by using
the talent meditate in the talon tab of
magic which replaces the shouts which
then shoots you into this dream world
the base game has the three generic
trees but the new dlc forgotten stories
adds lycanthropy and phasmalist in
simple terms lycanthropy is the werewolf
and phasmalist is for soul gems and
enchanting
this is enderall's version of the skill
tree except way more interactive
you start from the bottom then go all
the way up to the top in any way you
choose just like normal but you're
actually in there in person picking the
skills for yourself most of the beginner
skills will give you talents which are
small buffs that last a short amount of
time
one of them boosted my one-handed damage
for seven seconds once that seven
seconds was up i could cast the talent
again with no negative effects so i was
constantly using it in multiple fights
the skill tree was a really cool
experience the first time being able to
walk around and look at the trees in
person like that was truly amazing
to exit simply meditate again and you're
back to where you started when you left
almost like you paused and went up to
the menus to level up and then back just
like in skyrim except more interactive
all of this represents the basics of
enderall's combat and i'm truly amazed
as i've mentioned constantly i still
cannot shake the habit of using a
one-handed heavy armor character but an
ender all took me a full 10 minutes to
make the switch almost immediately to a
full magic character
besides the magic just being fun to use
i needed to do as much damage as
possible while taking as little damage
as possible and archery and magic
allowed me to do that perfectly so i
opted for magic the thing that confused
me was that the map was actually pretty
small
close to dragonborn dlc size i was
expecting a much larger world until i
realized the next mechanic of ender all
is that there's no
waiting or traditional fast travel now
the game isn't trying to torture you
about this when entering the first city
called the ark you can fast travel to
the different districts within the city
by interacting with the signs
if you need to go to a specific town
there's most likely going to be a scroll
labeled for which you can use to
teleport to the location of the town
almost immediately
alternatively there's also going to be a
combo of spells the first one allows you
to place a marker anywhere on the map
with the second one being able to
teleport you to that marker no matter
where you are
for more true fast travel methods there
are the myriads which are located on the
maps as these towers
these towers house creatures that will
teleport you to other towers of course
if this is too bothersome for you there
are mods that exist out there that add
waiting and fast travel back into the
game but it's intended to be played
without it but before you get any of
this information you
have to go through the intro and might i
say it's a bit of an interesting one
my my i totally forgot what a mess i
left here
but i was right wasn't i a real gem
we've got here
bring me a nice crisp piece of meat
bring me a nice crisp piece of meat
bring me a nice crisp piece of meat like
i said
very interesting the game already is
just mesmerizing to look at on ultra
settings and the first area really
conveys that everything is more colorful
and vibrant compared to skyrim's bleak
and depressing world and the sound
design is top tier with the music being
some of the best i've heard in a game in
a while
and since we're on the topic let's
discuss the story i won't spoil any end
game missions simply the first couple
acts which can be done in about two to
three hours assuming you don't get
sidetracked the start
is you having this recurring nightmare
of your family claiming you killed them
that's the intro then you awake on a
ship with your partner
you are refugees fleeing a recent war
and snuck on a ship to start a new life
eventually you do end up being caught by
the captain your friend is killed and
you're thrown off the ship you arrive on
the beach somehow alive but before you
wake up you see these constant visions
none of it making sense
now but will make tons of sense as you
slowly understand what the visions mean
throughout the game
and depending on some of your future
choices you may be able to see these
visions in person
after some exploring talking with people
and more crazy visions you meet jess
barr one of the three companions of the
game and personally one of the best
voice acted characters i've ever
listened to i can't put my finger on it
but there's something strange about you
and that intrigues me what do you say he
is where the story truly starts as he
takes a journey along to assist you in
your troubles which leads you down a
rabbit hole of craziness as you start
piecing together information and
learning about the island's history
things like the high ones the cleansing
the light burns and the red madness all
things that sound very vague at face
value but end up being explained in time
as the more you progress through the
story the more you understand
jaspar is a good segue to companions as
the companions you can choose from after
some time will allow you to return the
favor and help them with their troubles
and companion quests
these do have a deadline so you can't
just put these off to the very end you
do have to do these relatively quickly
the whole point of these is to allow you
to interact with your companion more and
learn more about them it's a small
detail but a fantastic one at that
it's something i always wish skyrim
added to their companions now to be fair
they have a dozen or so companions so
maybe just the more important ones will
be getting quests there are a whole
bunch of other things about this game
that are unique from knowledge points
and magic symbols that appear in random
places that just make this whole
experience fantastic and if anything
this is the true fresh experience for
skyrim players
getting mods that change the base game
are cool and switching up current
strategies in the current game can help
as well but these are just small things
that'll only change up the pace for a
couple hours at most that's why i saved
bruma and enderall for last as these are
the very definition of a fresh new
experience one being a dlc which is part
of the main game and the other being a
whole unique
ip with very little brought over from
the game in terms of its mechanics both
of which serve the players in different
ways allowing them to have the true
fresh experience we've discussed many
mods
in this section and honestly i could
have brought up so many more as there's
just a plethora of mods that exist
all of them being very unique in their
own ways sadly we just don't have the
time but that being said though this is
the end of our journey and i thank you
for coming along with me everything
we've discussed i personally believe
are the answers to the question why is
skyrim a game that hasn't had a
significant update since 2016
still played after nine years for the
harmonizing music the iconic story the
nostalgic memories you've all made
across the years
all of it i believe is the answer to
that simple question hopefully you all
enjoyed this video i've got a bunch more
games to include in this series but i'm
bound to miss some so let me know what
you'd like me to cover in the future
after skyrim it's only fair our next
couple videos like this cover the other
great bethesda series and we'll be
starting that series with fallout 3.
as i stated before thank you for joining
me on this journey through the wondrous
world of the other skulls 5 skyrim and
i'll see you soon goodbye
[Music]
you